about 10 seconds until it starts yeah
okay good evening everybody and welcome
to this evening's virtual meeting of
stratfor raven district council's
planning committee my name is councillor
peter richards and i will be chairing
the meeting this evening a little bit of
housekeeping to start with if i may
the this meeting is being live streamed
and it is being recorded for publication
on the council's website and
youtube members you will have been
provided with the council etiquette for
virtual meetings in advance of this
meeting just to reiterate a few points
for you though please make sure your
device is fully charged or charging if
you could please
mute your microphone when you're not
speaking and then of course unmute it
when
you are called to speak please indicate
in the chat bar if you wish to speak
um if for any reason
you have any i.t issues or encounter any
i.t issues
or broadband issues please do your best
to get back into the meeting as soon as
you can
two numbers have been put into our
meeting chat for that
uh to give you some help you will have
been deemed to have left the meeting at
the point that you lose
connection um and we will continue if we
are core at uh please do try and rejoin
as soon as you possibly
can we have a lot to get through tonight
so please if we can keep our questions
and answers
as concise and to the point as possible
it would be greatly
appreciated uh we have just confirmed i
have
uh in presence of the council's legal
legal officer
uh confirmation from all members that
they are here and president can
uh come here and see the meeting and
have read all of
our papers officers that are present
online
with us tonight from democratic services
we have olivia quinn
from legal we have ross chambers and
from our planning department we have
in no particular order amy flute paul
thompson and joe brook
and our planning manager is alice cosnet
alex i think you might have something
you'd like to say
yes thank you chairman my role is to
provide impartial advice and to assist
members in their decision
taking thank you marvelous thank you
very much
for the benefit of members of the public
um when you come to speak
you will be given a commencement amount
of time depending on the number of
speakers i'll let you know what that is
um if you press star and six on your
phone
keypads that will unmute your microphone
and we will be able to hear you i'll
remind you when you're called
and we will also give you a 30 second
warning before your speaking time is up
just so that you
uh you know you're approaching your your
time limit
okay let's dive straight in so uh
first item is apologies olivia do we
have any apologies please
i think so we've got apologies from
councillors crump
curtis eden and paris
fabulous thank you very much and any
disclosures of interest from our
committee members
please now first of all we have
counsellor adam
thank you um just uh notify the
committee
that i am the ward member for item four
and so i was stepping down for that item
to speak
on behalf of my residents marvelous
thank you and
councillor mills please
thanks mr chairman um mr chairman i
like others today we probably received a
photograph sent on email to us on uh
item on 20 stroke
zero one eight five zero ful and
on the last application um
i do know the um developer the
applicants
so i shall be sitting out
okay thank you very much councillor
mills
will i have to leave the meeting all
together on that last one
uh you will yes and unfortunately there
are no other
items left after that so um yeah feel
free to leave at that point
well i don't want to but yeah i can't
sit here and look on no
oh you i'm i mean you can observe but
you can't take part yes so thank you i'd
like to reserve
absolutely fine i'd like to observe
thank you okay
um i can confirm that we have indeed
received some uh images
in relation to application uh sorry item
for its application twenty zero one
eight five zero if you will it has gone
to all committee members
um uh uh so um no need for anyone else
to uh to make that declaration
there being no other uh declarations of
interest um in the meeting chat
we will move then to the minutes of our
previous meetings is everyone
just a quick hand show is everyone happy
that i signed the minutes um at our next
available opportunity
um i believe that's unanimous
yeah perfect that is unanimous right
our first item which is application
number 20
uh zero one two two two very
beechcroft in uh dark lane in tittington
our presenting officer is amy flute amy
are you there hello chairman can you
hear me
certainly can great whenever you're
ready it's over to you
great i will just share my presentation
with you so if you could just let me
know when you could see it that would be
appreciated
okay we do have a presentation in front
of us
great um
okay i will start thank you
the application site edged red is to the
north west of dark lane tiddington
planning permission was granted for a
replacement dwelling
the replacement dwelling was not built
in accordance with the approved details
this proposal seeks to regularize
changes retrospectively
the dwellings footprint as built is now
being shown
in the context of neighbouring
properties
they can the consented scheme is shown
on the left
and the changes being sought include
alterations to the facing materials now
um render will be used as the main
material
loss of dorm windows on the southeast
elevation
alterations to the porch arrangement
increased ridge height throughout
roof lights to enable a second floor in
the roof
alterations to the dormer arrangement on
the northwest
elevation
[Music]
alterations to the chimney design and
a reduction in the number of side-facing
windows
the ground floor plans as proposed can
now be seen
the proposal now includes a second floor
room in the roof which is shown
on this floor plan as you can see
bedroom six is the room within the roof
the proposed landscape scheme can now be
seen
this image is taken at the junction of
dark lane with tinnington road
looking in a northerly direction towards
the application
site
we are now immediately outside the
application site
where dark lane forks the application
site is just behind the trees
this image is showing the front of the
of the application site and the proposal
as built
the application site can now be seen in
the context of the neighbouring property
bockentine now known as bay trees when
looking in a westerly direction along
dark lane the rear of the property
can now be seen in relation to the
access road
off dark lane
a close-up of the rear and side
elevation
is now being shown
and now some images showing properties
within the immediate street scene
the principle of a dwelling has been
previously accepted in this location
it is not considered that the proposal
would have a detrimental impact on the
character of the street scene or
neighbouring immunity
chairman the recommendation is to grant
the application should
grant the application subject to the
conditions and notes as detailed within
the committee report
i would also draw your attention to the
update sheet
thank you chairman
fantastic thank you very much there is a
very small update as you mentioned on
the update sheet i'm sure members have
already read it uh but if you haven't
now's your opportunity okay let's move
straight to our speakers we have no
parish or town councillors registered so
our first speaker is mr simon
ewing on behalf of the residents mr
ewing are you there can you hear me
you may need to press start and 6 on
your phone keypad enabled to be able to
unmute yourself
star and 6.
mr ewing i'm not sure if you can or
can't hear me but if you could please
press star and six
on your keypad to unmute yourself
maybe another few seconds
ah mr ewing is that yes
fabulous we can we can hear you now yes
thank you very much welcome
this evening you um you have three
minutes in which to speak
um so whenever you are ready to go
please do start we will give you a 30
second warning as you're approaching the
end of that time
otherwise it's over to you okay
i speak on behalf of the majority of the
residents of dark lane
and school lane affected by this we
strongly object to this application the
applicant set out from the start to
build a house that is much bigger and
taller than the one that had been
approved
the house is wider and deeper and 1.2
metres taller
there's an enlarged first floor in large
first door and enlarged windows
a second floor has been added so it's a
three-story building with
extra windows added at height the height
of the eaves has been raised
making the entire roof higher and more
overbearing
as a result of this extra height bulk
positioning
and overall mass the property is
overbearing with loss of amenities
suffered by surrounding neighbors
some are overshadowed due to the
significant extra height and suffer loss
of light
many suffer loss of privacy due to the
overlooking of their house
and garden from the extra windows in the
unapproved third story
and enlarged first floor windows the
street scene is adversely affected
there are other large houses in dark
lane but set much further back from the
road and not in such a prominent focal
position
and certainly not one meter from the
road boundary
in addition other than the planning harm
already mentioned we have significant
concern regarding the integrity of the
planning process
this applicant set out from the start to
build a house that stands today
and not the house he had approval for he
has repeatedly submitted incorrect and
contradictory plans
and attempted a land grab of council
owned land and trees
the plans you have before you today are
still at variance and therefore cannot
all be correct
the applicant deceived we neighbors by
making various verbal and written
promises
thus avoiding any significant opposition
to the first application
then from the pouring of the foundations
onwards he ignored those promises
and the planning approval and built
something very different
if the house stands had been applied for
in the original application
to replace the then existing small
bungalow would it have gained approval
we as neighbors and the ward councillor
would almost
would most certainly have objected if
this application is passed it will set a
very dangerous precedent
if an applicant is allowed to build
whatever he wants and deceive the
neighbors and make a mockery of the
planning process
and he sends a clear message to every
builder and developer that planning
approval is merely a rough guide
and it's okay to build whatever you
choose uh it is not only the degree of
harm caused by the buildings itself but
also the harm that would be caused
the honesty integrity of the planning
process and the fact that the decent
council taxpayers and voters of
stratford-union district
would lose trust in the planning system
in conclusion we object to this
application as due to its extra height
size position and mapping this over
large property in this location
has an unacceptable adverse effect on
the amenities of surrounding property in
the local area
by overlooking loss of privacy shadowing
loss of light
visually overbearing impact and
detrimental effect on the street scene
incidentally the one letter of support
is from his sister who lives opposite
that's it thank you for listening mr
ewing thank you very much if you could
just hold on the line for a second when
i see
if counsellors have any questions for
you members if you could please indicate
in our chat if you would like to ask me
you in a question
[Music]
someone's phone's going off i'm
going to take that as a no so mr ewing
thank you very much for your time thank
you for your contribution this evening
you're probably best place to continue
to watch on the live stream so if you
want to hang up your phone now watch on
the live stream that's that's probably
the best option
but thank you again for your
contributions thank you
marvelous okay let's move to our next
speaker then who is keith williams the
agent for the application
mr williams are you there stand six to
one mute please
it was a bit of a glitch but i think
you're there
um can you hear me keith williams
speaking
keith hi yes good evening we can i think
do you have the live stream running in
the background
out of interest i do i've just muted it
for you
good man i it's very disconcerting
hearing my own voice coming back at me
uh keith you you know the uh you know
the scores three minutes 30 second
warning whenever you're ready do feel
free to begin
good evening councillors the applicants
have asked me to apologize on their
behalf
for the fact that the works have taken
place which are not in accordance with
the approved plans for the replacement
dwelling
they have asked me to point out that
they are not developers or builders
and this is the first time they've been
involved in building a new house
all they wanted to do was to create a
new family home
one they can be proud of and one which
is in keeping with the area
the principle of the development is not
at issue and the sole matter before you
tonight
is whether the design and forms of the
house has built
is acceptable the fact that that it is a
retrospective application
is not relevant to that consideration
the applicants are sorry that the
development has caused upset to some of
their new neighbours
however like your officer i find the
dwelling to be appropriate to the area
and that it does not harm the amenities
of nearby properties
or the wider locality the dwelling sits
on a sizeable plot
in an established residential area
within the divined
built up area boundary the area is
characterized by large detached
dwellings
the new house is of a high quality
design and
i agree with your officer that is in
keeping with the other dwellings in dark
lane
the slight increase in the width of the
dwelling from the approved plans
about 20 centimeters does not make a
difference to the impact of the dwelling
when viewed along dark lane
nor does the slight increase in depth
circa 40 centimeters
this change brings the dwelling a bit
closer to the road
but the difference is not discernible
further you will note the dwelling sits
behind existing trees
and hedging on the road frontage and
that it does not come forward
of the adjacent property the height of
the dwelling has built is not excessive
nor out of place the dwelling would not
dominate its surroundings
nor otherwise adversely affect the
street scene
the changes from the proposed so from
the approved scheme
do not bring the dwelling significantly
closer to neighbouring properties
and the distance to them still greatly
exceeds your guidelines
the dwelling does not overshadow
adjacent properties nor affect
neighbours and privacy all of these
points have noted and agreed by your
officer
the new porch adds further interest to
the design of the dwelling
and reflects the approved design of the
house
it does not harm the street scheme
as i seen in summary i submit the
dwelling as built is consistent with the
characteristics of the locality
and that there are no sound planning
reasons to resist the grant of planning
commission
moreover the planning officer has
undertaken a detailed assessment of the
developments
and found it to be appropriate and
acceptable having regarded the policies
of the course strategy
and the neighborhood plan as well as
your development requirements
spd i commend the officers report to you
and ask you to grant planning permission
thank you
mr williams thank you very much well
within your time so members do we have
any questions for
mr williams our agent i'll give you a
couple of seconds to type into the chat
will take that as a no okay thank you
very much for your contribution
um same rules apply feel free to
continue watching on the live stream
you're probably the best place to do
that
uh but thank you again for your
contribution thank you
cheers okay that leaves us with our uh
final speaker on this item news
councillor kate rolfe
council rob good evening welcome thanks
for your patience
you have opened no problem thank you
very much
um five minutes with a 30 second warning
um
whenever you're ready to begin over to
you okay good evening
way back in 2017 neighbours of
beechcroft and i met with the applicant
to discuss the original application
after three amicable sessions the
applicant reached
a compromise scheme which was acceptable
to both the neighbours
and the applicant which is why neither
the neighbours or myself objected
please note my comments on page 3 about
the planning statement at the time
changes were made after our meetings to
prevent any further height to the
building
the building would not be significantly
larger policy cs20
it will harmonize with neighbouring
properties and most importantly there
will be no habitable rooms and windows
at first floor level
it is now a three-story house the
planning officer considers that there is
no harm to
neighboring properties i would argue the
following this house is a completely
different house so that i've approved in
2017
it has not been amended this is a
different house altogether
it is taller wider is a three-story
house
and the garage is further forward of the
build line and an overly large
out of character porch see page nine by
the way of both at the bottom of the
sill
where it shows how much bigger it is
than the original application
i informed enforcement way back in
february about this and it took weeks
before the enforcement officer made
contact by which time the roof rafters
were on
the enforcement officer asked for the
applicant to produce amended plans which
took months by which time the building
was almost
finished the applicant told me on the
phone that when he and his wife first
visited
visited the property it was raining and
they asked the builder if he could build
them a porch
and the builder agreed and said planning
permission wouldn't be needed
the applicant also told me that the
third story would only be for his office
i asked if an office usually has an
ensuite bathroom
they had always intended to build
something different which is shown by
the original footprint
so harm i would suggest that the first
aspect of harm is of to our planning
system
get planning and promote approval for
something which satisfies the neighbors
and then build something completely
different
this of course sets a really dangerous
preston and if you as the committee
agree with the recommendation
you are also agreeing to this precedent
of building something different to that
approved
i can see developers up and down the
land using this as a good example
of how to get away with it harm
this house is larger taller by the way
um the agent just said it was 20
centimeters it's a meter and a half
taller and that's
borne out by the fact of amy um it has a
very large producing garage wall which
is the first thing you see as you enter
dark lane
it is completely out of character with
the lane policy be9 of the ndp
states replacement dwellings respect the
character of the surrounding area
policy has 20 of our call strategy talks
about replacement dwellings being overly
large
the original dwelling was a bungalow and
this new dwelling is an overly large
three-story house the original approved
plans forever two-story house smaller
and narrower
with no overly large obtrusive windows
at the back and no roof lights shining
across neighbouring properties
remember the original planning statement
it is interesting to note that the town
council's first response
was that the proposed development is
retrospective with flagrant breach of
planning rules
the builder applicant knew they were
building something different to that of
approved plans
and were only found out due to the
vigilance of the neighbours
it is now built and lived in the harm
that has been placed on the entire lane
and village is extraordinary
the harm that this precedence will cause
if you approve this
allowing something completely different
to be built it will send out shock waves
to people who have no faith in the
planning system
if this were to go ahead who is to say
it won't happen again
again i mention this will be used as an
example by developers for a long time to
come
i go back to a discussion i had with the
applicant who said that if the
application was not approved
he would gladly change it to suit i
suggest that discussion should take
place as soon as possible
to look at lowering the height removing
the porch to something more in keeping
and taking back the forward protruding
garage and removing the overly large
windows at the back
and covering over the roof lights so to
prevent the lights flooding the area
not all of these can be achieved easily
but there is a compromise to be had here
to satisfy the harm that has been caused
to so many people for a very long time
i know of one neighbor who's so upset by
what has happened
that they are seriously considering
moving because they are ashamed to live
in a district that has not listened to
them
i know this sounds overly dramatic but
you must realize
that apart from the personal harm to
many many residents
the house that has called being built is
completely different to the one approved
in 2017
if approved it will set a precedent that
this council may suffer the consequences
of
for a very long time thank you
okay thank you very much um members do
we have any questions for our ward
member please negate the chat
if you do i'm seeing
very little action from our counselors
right now so
um there's nothing in the chat so kate
thank you very much
sorry counselor rolf thank you very much
for your contribution um you can of
course stay on to watch
the final parts of these proceedings
okay
uh we will go to questions and points of
clarification to our
officer do members have any points of
clarification or questions
for our officer councillor dixon was
first in councillor dixon named to you
thank you chairman on page seven amy
um you mentioned that concern was raised
regarding the introduction of the roof
lights
can you confirm if the floor level to
the sill of the roof lights
uh is sort of 1.7 meters or can you
actually stand on the floor and look
down on the neighboring properties and
secondly uh the
development obviously the additional
floor space
is quite a chunk of that actually the
porch thank you amy
thank you councillor if i just um share
my screen
screen with you i can show you a plan
which has been provided
um as part of this submission um which
is
from the rooflight windows um in the
roof
which then looks out to the rear of the
property can you see that
i certainly can if you're able to make
that full screen that would be quite
helpful
yeah please that definitely looks a bit
more than the roof window
it looks like one of those that's got a
kind of little um
projecting opportunity to stand out onto
it
yeah like
yeah i think in the design um i think
from from that image um
because of how the reef is designed you
can see i think from the images that
there isn't
it just doesn't directly overlook um
into the neighboring property what you
can see
is the um garden of the application site
um and if i go back to the if i go back
to the approved plans
um in the in the roof lights
unfortunately i don't have a cross
section so i can't confirm to you
um the exact position um in relation to
obviously
how high it is from the from the floor
in the roof
um moving on to your second point um
on the floor space the um
so the the porch element um hasn't been
included within the floor space
calculation
and the the increase in the floor space
is predominantly from
um the addition at second floor level
thank you very much amy lovely thank you
very much amy um councillor jennings has
a question for you as well council
journeys
thank you chairman just a quick question
here and this is retrospective
um so the house has already been built
under new
pd rights you can add an extra flaw
um we should mitigate the height issues
i mean house is basically going to get
bigger
um through pd rights and was this house
completed
before the cutoff date which i think is
at some point in 2018 or so or
i'm not quite not 100 sure on it but uh
is is that the case in this
thank you counsellor so my understanding
and i will clarify this with alice
is that um because it's a new build um i
don't think it would qualify for the um
additional committed development right
which has been introduced recently for
the additions in the roof
um in addition there is a condition
which has been carried across from the
original consent
which does remove committed development
rights so the council would have control
in the future for any future
developments which fall under
um schedule two part one classes a to e
which is householder extensions okay
thank you very much lovely thank you
very much and counselor adam
please thank you chairman um there's
just a question
in terms of the volume across the
the property and how that may have
changed over well from the from the
original
to the what's being proposed now i
couldn't find it in the report but
i might be missing it um is there a
measure that we've
we've done in terms of the volume
increase
thank you councillor and because the
application the application site isn't
within the greenbelt so we wouldn't
necessarily look into volumes
as far as um this application is
considered
it would come down to um whether or not
um the building would be considered to
be appropriate with regards to
its visual appearance um and whether or
not it would be
um inappropriate within the context of
obviously what it was being replaced
from annex street scene alice do you
have anything to add to that at all
no i don't think so i think you covered
that off well amy i think the only point
to make is the most significant changes
with regards to the the ridge high
increase so in terms of although we
don't have those those volume
differences for the reasons amy's just
provided i think the um
ridge height increase is 1.2 meters um
amy that's correct isn't it
that is correct and that's compared from
the plan which was um approved and on
the decision notice
compared to the um proposed elevation
plans which have been submitted as part
of this application
okay that's useful thank you fabulous
counselor dixon has another one for you
council dixon thank you chairman amy
would it be reasonable for us if we were
minded to
make any adjustment to this uh proposal
to require fixed roof lights instead of
the opening variety which is obviously
available there
i'm minded to think when i asked if it
was 1.7 from the floor
a situation whereby ideally you should
not be able to
as it were look down or sideways etc
and those roof lights to me do look
um so they could certainly be intrusive
potentially
it would have to come down to whether or
not it would be considered
reasonable and as part of that we would
have to test whether or not it would be
enforceable
to obviously condition condition that
out um
and that would be something which
obviously members would have to satisfy
themselves that they
are happy that it meets the test of
reasonableness um alice do you have
anything to add to that at all
i think the only thing i would add thank
you amy is obviously the assessment
officers have made is that
views out of those room flights don't
cause such significant harm to justify
refusal or indeed justify
that condition being applied so that's
officer's view that that condition isn't
necessary so it wouldn't meet the tests
as amy said if members are minded to
disagree with that and do
think that unacceptable views would be
accorded to neighbouring properties then
by
all means they may wish to add that as a
condition but i would just say that
obviously the applicant would have the
right to appeal against that condition
um and i think officers we've given that
we haven't recommended would be that
that may be a challenging appeal to to
defend
fabulous thank you very much both of you
um while we're on that topic i just have
a quick question for you
from amy on page seven you talk about
the 45 25 degree sight line rules and
there is a minimal breach
but i'm trying to understand what that
minimal breach means so what is minimal
in that
sense um minimal was that
it was very slight um so
that i don't unfortunately i don't have
anything i can show you which sets it
out
um but it was it wasn't considered that
it would be harmful enough to
for me to warrant a refusal so sorry i
may have misum
phrased my question but um what is the
actual breach
so is it uh you know one degree the
wrong way or
a couple of meters or what um if i it
let me share my screen it's difficult to
sort of
explain um if i go to
um
if i go to this plan here can you can
you see that
we can um so it's ever so slight um can
you see
the corner um where i'm hovering the
mouse
and so there's a kitchen window here
next door
which is already um the existing
development at [ __ ] time
already breaches that 45 degree sight
line so if you take the 45 degree sight
line
um coming out from the rear elevation of
blocking time where the window's
positioned
and it's it's ever so slight so i mean
in
in that sense it's grazing the wall or
is it
a meter of the wall no it's not it's not
a meter it wasn't significant enough for
me to consider that we would have
grounds um
for me to obviously warrant refusal on
impact on neighboring immunity
i understood okay thank you very much um
there look
looks like there's no further questions
for uh for amy at the moment so let's
move into our
debate who would like to kick us off
someone must counselor mills council
mills
over to you thanks thanks mr chairman
um looking at the report uh
we look at um councillor kate ross
statement here um its
third story was never on the original
plans it's
um in fact kate's put it's a meter in
height higher and then you go on to page
six and the officer actually says
this with the exception of the enlarged
ridge height you know it's it's 1.2
meters higher
this this building um
it it just seems that a lot and it's a
very nice looking house don't get me
wrong but
i mean they they've just got completely
over the top here haven't they they've
you know throwing the original
application out of the window and just
built what they want
by the look of it uh a bit confused at
the moment mr chairman so i'll shall
wait to see what everybody else has to
say thank you
okay thank you very much council mills i
would uh just at this point say
um whilst uh this is a retrospective
plan application we're not looking to
compare this with the previous
application
we are looking at what's in front of us
now um and if we consider
this application to be a breach of
policy then of course
we can move towards a refusal but if we
think it is within policy then we move
to a grant
i just want to make that clear we're not
comparing to a previous and we're not
making a decision on a previous
um sorry casa jennings is next up
councillor jennings
yep thank you i know just a quick
comment
and about those deluxe windows the
things on the side of those are actually
safety features
um so you you don't fall out if you open
the window
i just happen to have gone to a place
and saw that a couple of weeks ago
um but on this on this planning
application
it looks very similar to me i really
don't have a problem with this
at all um it
is it's slightly bigger it's slightly
bigger
um i i i would
really struggle to come up with some
some reasons to go against the officer's
decision on this
and i'm mindful to propose
that uh we go ahead and grant this
planning application
thank you very much council jennings uh
councillor adam is next on my list
council adam
thank you um i don't feel particularly
comfortable with this one
i think for a lot of the reasons that um
the ward member did set out especially
given the negotiation that the applicant
had with
uh residents beforehand um
some of the specific concerns i have um
i think relate to the the scale and
i think one of the benefits almost that
this is a retrospective
um application is that we're not talking
about things that are just on a piece of
paper we can see whether it's
bulkier we can see whether it's
overbearing or not
now the people who are affected by this
whether whether it's acceptable or not
are are able to make that assessment
in full wide of what is there in front
of them and
i think that gives that that viewpoint
more weight
uh in my opinion in terms of how we as
the committee and how
we as a planning authority assess that
overbearing impact because
these are things that aren't necessarily
um completely confined to
um the measurements that are set out in
the documents
um that said the the justification in
the report seems to be
that um other properties on the street
are
large um in scale and bulk from the
photos i saw this seemed significantly
larger
and bulkier and so i'm not comfortable
in in supporting the this this go
through
in the same veins then as a result of
of the the variation um i'm i'm
not at this point
uh proposing that we go against the
officer's recommendation
that's certainly how i mined it to to go
uh and if we can
um substantiate the the concerns that
have
been put forward very clearly by the war
member and local residents
into something that's backed up by our
policy then i'd be very
strongly minded to support that okay
thank you cancer adam
now i remiss of me to not ask councillor
jennings he suggested that he was
mindful to propose grant but
uh that wasn't a committal to a proposal
i just want to check
with you it was yours of a full proposal
it was a full proposal it was a formal
appraisal good
okay thank you very much um councillor
hensha seraphin is my next
uh speaker counselor sergeant uh
yeah thank you chair my very grave
concerns about this
uh type of application um
when when you're given permission to
build a house at a certain size
certain height then you should stick to
it
you should not just do what you want and
get away with
it because everybody be doing that i
think this is not
not right at all in a practical sense
and
with um the amount of people objecting
uh an award member that should weigh
heavily
on the committee to reassess this
application
thank you thank you
councillor hendrich serafin um just to
reiterate what i said what
i before we do have to have planning
grounds to go against this
um whilst i fully support your
frustration and irritation
uh with retrospectives um applications
and i've made my views known on
retrospective applications before
the reality is that it's part of our
legal framework
and we must find reasons to refuse
policy reasons to refuse
not just it's it's not what was granted
the first time so this is a formal
application separate from the previous
and i just wanted to reiterate that
point um counselor dixon is my my next
speaker counselor dixon
thank you chairman yes i'm going to say
essentially we've got to look at what we
have here and what what we
might have wish to have had a situation
i think where if the
application had initially been for what
we've now got
would we have refused it on grounds of
overbearing
i must admit obviously i did have some
concerns regarding those roof windows
and that additional floor level
but having seen that last
plan where we saw its juxtaposition
in association with its neighboring
properties the separation that is
available
there etc i am less concerned regarding
impact upon the neighbors etc and
therefore we're left with
the additional height of the roof now
my calculation indicates that the floor
space has increased by 10
um on what was actually approved
initially
but do i think that if we refuse this
now
would we succeed at appeal in defending
such a decision requiring because
obviously
one assumes that the applicant would not
start changing the roof line without at
least going to appeal
to keep what they've currently got so i
must admit
uh reluctantly i would um second the uh
the proposal by
councillor jennings mars thank you very
much councillor dixon
and finally uh council kendall
thank you for your patience councillor
one of you ready thank you
uh council dixon beat me to it i'm happy
to second
look i mean we've got to be clear on
this it's really really important that
as a committee we are seen to understand
the procedures and continually talking
about you know
how we don't like retrospective it it's
not
we're not putting them on trial having a
retrospective application
and as much as we don't like you we've
got to be very clear that's nothing to
do with our deliberations here tonight
there are no planning material planning
grounds and
therefore i'm more than happy to back
the uh recommendation
from the officer councillor kendall
very concise couldn't agree more let's
move to a vote we have a proposal
from councillor jennings it's been
seconded from councillor dixon to
approve
er to grant sorry in line with the
officer's recommendation i will go first
councillor richards
four okay cancer fleming
catcher flowering unlikely really but
yes i have to go
for councillor kendall
councillor kendall four councillor adam
councillor adam against councillor dixon
councillor dixon four councillor hunter
seraphin
council interest in against cancer
jennings
council jennings four
and councillor miles
council mills against chairman
chair that's six four and three against
sorry i couldn't do my math then thank
you very much olivia
okay so committee therefore resolves to
grant application twenty zero one
two two two very in line with the
officer's recommendation
and the update sheet thank you everyone
sorry to interrupt can i check those
numbers because i think they add up to
more than we've got
[Music]
olivia could you just you are muted at
the moment
my fault that's one two three four five
four and three against
thank you chairman thank you so uh it
either way uh we're resolving to grant
application uh twenty zero one two two
two
very thank you very much um do we we
have our parish
council in for a speaker for our next
item do we have all our other speakers
as well
i minded just to dive straight in and i
hope that they do
join us during i'm just trying to get
the agent
chairman okay no problem i think we'll
make a start
sorry my cat has just decided to come in
and wants to join the meeting
um we will make a start so um our next
application
is uh application reference twenty zero
one eight five zero ful
uh as garages adjacent to 27 league
crescent in long itchington
our case officer is joe brooke joe
whenever you're ready please go ahead
thank you chair uh let me just set the
presentation
i take it everybody can actually see
that we can indeed
brilliant the application site is
located at the southern edge of
longitude as indicated by the black dot
before you
the application site lies within the
village longitude with residential
development situated to the north and
west
along the crescent while presently 81
dwellings are under construction to the
east
and they're actually under 2014 2018
permissions
respectively and as set out in the
report the grand union canal is located
to the rear
application site and presently the site
contains a number of redundant garages
also set out in the report
as you can see the plan for you is an
aerial shot which gives good
good indication of the whole site so
this is lee crescent
extending all the way around that is the
application site itself with the
redundant garages
this is uh the old boat hill pub and
this
is where the uh 81 dwellings have been
approved
this is a grand union canal to area
the proposal is seeking to free
dwellings within the site
plot one will be situated to the north
west of the site and plots two and three
will situate to the south
if permitted the properties would be set
as 7.4 meters to ridge
one and a half stories in height so as
you can see here there's plots two and
three and that is plot one
you come off league present into the
garage site and these are the
neighboring properties number 25
number 27 grand union canal to rio
that is plot the elevation drawings for
plot two and three
these are that's plot one it gives you a
good indication of what is being
proposed material wise
it will be finished in a red brick to
match the existing area
and also all the properties are
proposing three bedroom dwellings
this is the entrance to the site so this
will be coming off league presence
that's the neighboring properties number
25 number 27
gary sites in the sea and you see the
old boat into the rear
as you can see the garages at the minute
are redundant and
have i started becoming quite derelict
and dilapidated
through the course of time
this is a respected dwelling so the
lineal pattern along the crescent knight
is number 27
that's number 25 which have the side
windows looking over
onto the application side
that is the situated longer and now
the grand canal these are the
developments that's going up to the ec81
dwelling so you can't see the ridge
lines from the application site itself
and this is taken from the grand canal
so that literally if it was approved
that's where the dwellings would be
situated
that's the end of the presentation i sat
out in the office report the application
is considered the comply of all policy
requirements especially considering the
latest relevant appeal decisions
overall the proposed development would
respect the existing volatility of the
australian bill form
in terms of size scale mass height and
materials while ensuring adequate living
means for future residents
officer recommendations there for
approval
you'll also note in the update sheet a
parking survey was supplied from the
paris council
in which wc highways have reviewed and
also still maintain and no objection to
the application
thank you jay thank you very much um
superb as always members as uh joe said
we do have a reasonably substantial
update in the update sheet i know you've
already read them but do have it to hand
just in case you need to refresh your
memories
let's move to our first speaker uh for
this item who is counselor atkins from
long itchington council council atkins
can you hear me
you will need to press star and sex to
unmute yourself sounds like you already
have
can you hear me oh we can indeed
you may have muted yourself again
cancer atkins can you hear us okay hello
i think we've got you we can we've got
you this time
sorry there was a minor technical glitch
you've got three minutes we'll give you
a few second warning for your time's up
whenever you're ready please start thank
you i speak on behalf of long ishington
parish council and the residents
if the development of four houses has
previously been
refused as being overcrowded and a harm
to neighbouring properties
then we see nothing which radically
changes these two issues when the
development is reduced to three
the access to the site shown in photos
sent to you earlier
is extremely narrow and not suitable for
any vehicle other than a car
or a very small van so bin lorries
emergency vehicles delivery vans etc
would not be able to access the
dwellings at all
and this would present a nuisance to
other residents in league crescent
indeed how would builders vehicles
access the site during construction
whilst parking is provided for the new
residents a significant number of
garages have been removed for
long-standing residents of the street
thereby exacerbating a growing problem
for motorists and pedestrians
we object to the principle of selling
off garages on all orbit estates and
replacing with housing for this very
reason
garage space is now being replaced by
three houses with potentially six
cars entering and exiting lee crescent a
cul-de-sac
on a daily basis their visitors would
definitely need to find somewhere to
park
our parking survey found that drivers
often face problems with parking and
pedestrians are forced off the road
because of pavement parking
occasionally ambulances have not been
able to get through
the other parking professional survey we
commissioned showed that whilst
theoretically there is some parking
capacity
the method of calculation presupposes
that cars are able to park on both sides
of each road
that this in reality would not be
possible and still maintain an
unhindered highway
these 1950s roads are narrow and not
designed for today's number and width of
cars
our emerging neighborhood plan states
that small-scale developments on
previously developed land
would only be supported if the new use
would lead to an enhancement in the
character and appearance of the site
and its immediate surroundings any
enhancement provided by this is because
orbit allowed the garages to deteriorate
so much
in the last five years longitude has
received 289 new dwellings
when our target as a category 1 lsv was
about 113
we've had an increase in a third of
residents and dwellings
any extra dwellings that lead crescent
do not contribute positively to this
figure
as the applicant has claimed they do
finally the current
valued and much used pedestrian access
from league crescent to the canal
towpath
would disappear this negates the
planner's argument that the lack of
residential immunity space
would be compensated for by access to
the canal for new residents
we urge you to refuse this application
thank you
council atkins thank you very much that
is well within your time
uh members do we have any questions for
our parish council
speaker please indicate the chat if you
do
i'm seeing very little action at the
moment so i'm going to take that as a no
so
council reckons thank you again for your
contribution this evening you're
probably best placed to hang up the
phone and continue to watch the live
stream
uh online but thank you again thanks
okay our next speaker is our agent mr
ross middleton
mr middleton are you there please press
961 mute yourself
mr middleton can you hear us star and
six to unmute yourself
can you hear me we can't you sound very
distant
at the moment we can hear you just
is that any better a little bit yeah
it's getting better as uh the closer you
get to the microphone i think
um uh we
we can hear you now no problem we can't
we can hear you now and it's much
clearer so
you've got three minutes we'll give you
a 30-second warning whenever you're
ready please do begin
okay um well first of all we'd just like
to uh say thanks to the officer for
their hard work and
in getting the application to this point
a level of pragmatism which they've
shown
in both their deliberations and
discussions throughout the course of the
application
since its submission and i don't want to
rehearse what
the office has already been over um
particularly the planning history of the
sites is well documented within the
offices report however i would urge
members be mindful that this is a
distinctly different proposal
to the previous appeals scheme we're now
looking for
a proposal for three dwellings rather
than the foreign and it's it's
completely altered the um
the whole layout and the form of
development um
i think it's it's important that we
rehearse a few of the um the
fundamentals of this case the
development plan
um sets up the policies for this
proposal
and this development which is in front
of this wholly compliant with those
relevant elements from the development
plan which are
applicable to the determination of this
application as certain planning policy
terms the principle of residential
development of the site is completely
acceptable
moving on there is therefore i urge
members to remain mindful of the content
of the adoptive development plan which
takes privacy in the determination of
applications for development such as
this
as a side the council's emerging site
allocations plan also supports
development of the site whilst this
document has not yet passed through a
formal examination is a clear indication
of the council's long-term intention
to assist in the achievement of
sustainable housing like on sites
within settlement boundaries such as the
one in front of you at the present time
with the principle of the proposal
accepted perhaps a significant
point of note is that there have also
been no technical objection to this
proposal
and therefore there are no technical
reasons which would warrant a planning
reason for refusal
and this also includes highway safety
and parking matters which i'm aware
obviously they've just been highlighted
earlier but we've we've
had discussions with the local highway
authority and and
got to the point where they don't object
to this this application
i'm also aware of the comments made in
respect to the over provision of housing
within longitude in response to this i
would urge you that members remain
mindful of recent appeal decisions in
the district which are absolutely clear
that those housing targets within the
core strategy
are a cap on development and not a
captain they're not a cap on development
but they're
a guidance figure and this this site
would serve to be a windfall
um and provide complementary growth to
those larger sites which have been
allocated both within this settlement
and other settlements across the
district
there is a professional recommendation
in front of you from the council's case
officer which urges members to go out
and consent to this proposal
their assessment of this development is
set out within that report
is extensive and provides an exhaustive
discussion of the social economic and
environmental benefits associated with
this
proposal and
i think it's clear that this development
proposal
while smaller than the the previous um
is wholly compliant with the development
plan
and we have encountered no technical
objections during the course of this
this application orders
but members be mindful of those two
particular points during their
deliberations
fabulous mr middleton thank you very
much members do we have any questions
for our agent
councillor dixon has a question for you
council dixon
thank you chairman mr middleton um our
officers report
uh on page 26 is
talking about the access to the canal
the officers report reads you know i
consider that it is reasonable to attach
condition to require the provision of an
access point
from the development site to the
adjacent canal towpath
i would like to see it not only to the
canal tow pass i'd like to see it
through the site
is that your intention it would all
depend on the way in which the um
it would be our intention obviously if
there was a condition on there it would
be discharged in the manner that would
be seen
reasonable to the the council it would
it would be entirely within the
council's control if
if i am if a condition of that nature
was to be attached
to any forthcoming consent details to
discharge that condition
would have to be acceptable to the local
authority
okay um are there any other questions
for
our agents and please indicate in the
chat if you
are i've seen very little action so i'm
going to take that as a no
mr wilson thank you very much for your
contribution this evening as with other
speakers you're probably best served to
continue to watch the live stream
on on our website or through um through
youtube so
uh thank you again for your contribution
okay thank you very much
cheers and that brings us to our
ward member councillor adam council adam
good evening
you know the drill five minutes 30
second warning whenever you're ready
please start
thank you very much longington
neighborhood development plan is in the
late stages of development having
already been reviewed by this authority
and is close to referendum
this should therefore be given
significant weight as such this adds
particular relevance to the statement
that small-scale developments on
previously developed land will only be
supported
if the new use would be compatible with
the surrounding uses and lead to
enhancement in the character and
appearance of the site in its immediate
surroundings
it is demonstrated that this condition
will not be met by this development
nor will cs15 due to the site being
unsuitable for the following reasons
which is supported by evidence submitted
by the parish council relating to
parking
one visitor parking spacing is space is
required as par
as per part o development requirements
spd none has been provided and therefore
the development fails to meet the
parking requirements additionally tandem
spaces are being used
which is not preferred under a preferred
option under our own policies
expanding this out to lee present being
the only access road to the site
parking has been an ongoing issue for
residents and only stands to be
exacerbated by the removal of garages
and increased cars from the development
a recent
resident survey carried out by the
parish council found that two-thirds of
respondents
experienced problems with parked cars as
a driver and as a pedestrian
all almost the time and over half had
problems finding a place to park
all or most of the time further to this
a formal survey carried out by
consultants ndc
found that the two beats on the corner
with the application site entrance
experience over
subscription or the maximum number of
cars parked per space is available
the opposite side of the roads were not
parked on given a narrow naturally
present
this would unreasonably restrict access
and the flow of traffic
i myself have whilst walking uh on this
street not been able to remain on the
pavement the whole way down the road due
to curb parking
i hate to think how less able-bodied
persons manage
this is also an issue highlighted by the
report submitted
it is therefore demonstrable that there
is no capacity
um for even one additional car and
therefore even when assessed on a
case-by-case
assist the application fails to meet a
reasonable requirement for sustainable
development
under design the officer notes that the
garages are derelict and redundant
the existing structures may be in a
state of disrepair but the uses for the
site is
parking is far from redundant this has
been demonstrated by the parking service
and resident feedback
under name bringing amenity and
immediacy of future occupiers
it is noted that the distance between
units and existing properties
are below the minimum requirements in
two cases and two of the three units are
under the required 50 square meter
minimum for private residential immunity
requirements
all of which are unacceptable under part
f of the development requirements spd
the canal and rivers trust conditions
required increased distance between the
canal and the two units
and the removal of permitted development
rights to safeguard public immunity
these are clearly unachievable given the
app the application's failings under
part f
the office suggests suggests
conditioning access to the canal
from the site to accord with cs26
however given the density and layout of
the development
it will not be possible to replace the
existing pedestrian access
used by the public for decades and so
this will inevitably
be lost also sdc's waste and recycling
recommendations have been determined to
be unachievable
one of these shortcomings alone may be
acceptable given the right scheme
but there are now many which are mass to
create an unsuitable and unsustainable
scheme
and therefore gives significant grounds
for refusal under our own policies
the committee must consider the
application in front of them however
however relevant case law set precedent
the decisions being made
indeed the officer has included a
reference to an appeal case
uh in an attempt to do just that
relating to cs16
noting the housing numbers i refer the
committee to an application
in stockton for three units on a similar
sized plot within the built-up area
boundary
another local service village in my air
in my ward
similar to long itchington stockton has
seen significant numbers of housing over
the approximate recommendation in the
core strategy this application was
recommended for grant but was refused
on the decision letter it states that
stockton has significantly exceeded
its approximate housing allocation and
as such the weight that may be afforded
to the benefit of new housing delivery
and stockton
must be considered accordingly this
decision was appealed and the appeal
dismissed
the similarities in this application to
the stockton case demonstrate
fundamentally
that this authority does have the right
to refuse under court strategy policy
cs16
as proportional housing numbers are set
out by this document
i will repeat the figures included in
the officer's report the number of
houses already built for being built in
long itchington
is now 304. 2.7
times the recommended 112 by our own
core strategy
almost 70 percent of the total number
the local service village category wants
across the district
this is frankly ridiculous it makes a
mockery of our planning system
there has to be a reasonable limit
longitude has exceeded this
the emerging site allocation plan also
only attributed
uh limited weight but is being used to
define the physical compounds of the
village
therefore the chant roll out of the
reserve site should also be considered
being a significant part of this
document on itsington is in tears so
i'm gonna have to ask you to to uh to
give your final
sentence now that is your time up i'm
afraid no it's the last thing then would
be
uh one good planning reason can be
enough to go against the officers
recommendations and i have given you
several
uh and it's for this reason i would ask
you to refuse the application thank you
very much
thank you very much okay members do we
have any questions for our ward member
please indicate in the chat
if you do
there's nothing coming forward at the
moment
ah councillor henshaw sarafin is first
cancer servant
thank you chair uh counselor adam
can you elaborate on cs16
on this please 16.
um yes so i i i appreciate that
um it is a guide on that the numbers
here in in this policy are a guide but i
think what
when when saying that and saying that
it's not the number upper limit in and
of itself
ignores the reason for those numbers
being in the core strategy in the first
place
the reason that they are proportional to
the settlements
uh and the numbers required across the
district is so that we don't over stress
uh infrastructure so that we don't over
develop areas
uh and villages oh you know we've had
2.7 times the numbers that we were
meant to have based on this guide is
totally unreasonable
and and it flies in the face of the the
sentiment behind
the that that core strategy pretty much
okay thank you for that thank you thank
you
and cancer dixon has a question for you
as well council dixon
thank you chairman adam um using your
local knowledge i must admit
um i've got a patch of uh local ex local
authority housing association properties
in my patch
and i dare say we all have and equally
well i've got a lot
of parking issues but on the corner of
my site there is an area which is a
kind of a car park do any of the local
residents we saw the photographs of the
garages do any of them use that land
currently informally as somewhere to
park or do they invariably park outside
their own houses
um now most people do appear to park
outside their own houses
in recent history uh in relation to
applications going into this site
gates have been put up to stop any
access to the
to this site in particular um i think
that was around the time that the
application
started coming in i know that the gates
aren't always
always shut um and i have to check you
know with local residents to see how
often that's the case
but i think they were definitely
discouraged from parking there which is
why
there you know that's that's not a
regular aspect now because it was
it was discouraged by the landowner
thank you
i hadn't known any gates on the
photograph but obviously there must be
some there thank you
lovely thank you very much members
excuse me cancer adam
we have no further questions for you so
thank you very much please do continue
to stay on
um right let's move two questions for
our
officer do we have any points
clarification or questions
for joe councillor mills is first in
council mills
thanks mr chairman um joe um
just a a couple of things um
the what is the width of this road that
goes in i can see there's been no
objection from highways on this
uh but what is the width of the road
going into this site it looked quite
narrow on
on the plan there dude do we know
you you muted you moved to joe joe you
are muted at the moment
thank you this is
i couldn't give you a definitive whip uh
because that would have been
pretty much the job of highways to do
what i can say is
that the access down there was obviously
used for vehicles in the past
and highways do that assessment and
raise no ejection in regards to access
so if i if i gave you an approximate it
wouldn't be fair so that's the honest
truth
i i just wondered how the um
you know something like a fire engine
would get down there if there was a car
coming the other way and
would they be able to pass either side
you think you look honest
truth being with that same again is
highways and we also did consult with
fire and rescue
rejection with that so okay thanks that
also
missed the point there are there how
what is the park requirement on this is
it is it two
what it is is two parking unallocated
parking requirements for each dwelling
so that's
it meets up the spd
this is where it comes right the spd
also says for every two
three bedroom dwelling you should have
naught point two of space
for all of them so there's three
dwellings this goes to 0.6 of a visitor
space
for all three dwellings round it up it's
one additional
visitor parking space they don't meet
that one additional visitor parking
space
for all the three dwellings i hope that
makes it he's
set out in the report
i think i understand that castle mills
happy birthday
sorry i went i went for a second i lost
you all yes thank you very much
thank you marvelous uh councillor dixon
has a question for you
answer jason thank you chairman uh joe
um
i asked the uh uh mr middleton about the
the access to the canal
um the report you read that you'd like
to see an access point from the
development site i'd like to see it from
more than just three properties
um was it your intention that it should
be through the site so that it serves
the whole of the crescent
well yeah pretty much the reason being
is at the minute
although there's no designated um
footpath down there that's been recorded
by wc writes away
i did notice and it's also been
referenced in previous decisions
that there is uh a sort of an access
route that is down there that's
obviously been used now i don't know if
that's been used for over 30 years or
not
um unintended so i can't comment on that
but it would be nice to see if that
access was maintained
so that the estate and the free
dwellings could ensure that that's
carried on
that's what the condition is there and
obviously that would be discharged
if this was permitted at a later date so
that's why
it was recommended to keep that
condition so that it could still be
accessed
from the residents of the whole area
thank you joe
that's exactly what my thought
joe i've got no other members in the
meeting chat so i've got
a couple of just clarifications if i may
um the ward member mentioned residential
size part f of the spd
i'm not sure i really followed what he
was saying can you explain to me why
uh he might think something doesn't meet
that so
there's a few things first of all it's
correct that technically it doesn't mean
it on regards that one visitor parking
space for the whole
development so really if it was
absolutely incur correspondence with
that that's what he should do is provide
another one visitors parking space
but i've set out in the report why i
don't think that is
where i meet the standards of the appeal
the second thing sorry counselor is that
tandem parking is meant to be frowned
upon but it actually is frowned upon
and i've got the word in is thrown upon
under o2 park and residential estates
tandem parking spaces should not be used
where residential parking
is unallocated in shared circumstances
this isn't the case it's a private
estate tandem parking for the area and
they can get back out onto a private
area and then
and onto the main road so it is
allocated as a parking so that's not
quite correct that is under o2 parking
standards of the spd
okay thank you i'm actually quite clear
on parking i think um
i may have misunderstood what country is
saying but i think uh i understood it
that
it didn't meet the um the size of the
residential immunity size
oh okay apologies again so their
residential mean size is kind of true
so it is only guidance you've got to
remember the spd is actually guidance
not policy so
first of all the policy requirements for
it's 40 square meters i sat and reported
that
just short or two of the dwellings to
meet the 40 square meters
however you've also got appreciate the
surrounding circumstances and that the
fact that
that isn't going to be looking onto the
back of neighbouring properties or so
forth it's actually going to be looking
onto the back of the canal
with nice trees and so forth so any
future occupiers of dwellings
in my opinion can be alleviated by only
me only just not quite meeting 40 square
meters of private garden space
okay i'm going to ask um uh our planning
managers to give a bit more clarity to
that as well please
alex did you mind stepping in at that
point thank you chairman
i think something i just wanted to
clarify i think um joe
said that the recommended standard for a
three bed unit is 40 square meters the
spd actually requires 50 square meters i
think that was just an error so i just
wanted to correct that
so the spd requires 50 square meters uh
plot 1
provides 44 square meters and plot 2
requires 40. so they're the shortfall
but as
joe quite rightly said in the balance
and considering the location of the site
um officers didn't think that that
shortfall was sufficient enough to
justify a refusal
so in a nutshell um it's not a hard and
fast rule it's guidance
and given the location and the other
factors involved
taking this as a whole you're satisfied
exactly yeah that's correct
okay and the last bit that i want to ask
if i may before cancer dixon comes back
and has another one
um is about numbers again our woman was
quite robust about cs16 and numbers
um just quoted on uh a um
an appeal decision that's that's
happened i'm not privy to the detail of
that
can you give us an idea my understanding
is that it's not an upper limit
uh but provided infrastructure within
that village can sustain
the level of housing work that's being
introduced
that then we're okay to breach that that
num that guided number
can you give me your view and your
understanding of it so i'm clear please
that is pretty much the view and the
guidance um there's no denying that
along eastern turn as well over
the recommendation guidance and esp
sorry in the core strategy what you also
have to consider as the previous
approval
appeals on the site which were for four
dwellings the inspector raised no
issues in respect to the four dwellings
and the housing requirements for long
itchington as a whole
this is for free dwellings and therefore
it would be very hard pressed if we went
to appeal to say that that will be
a significant detriment to the
infrastructure area given that we have a
very recent appeal decision on that site
okay that's clear for me thank you very
much and councillor dixon
come back in on your question please
thank you chair
we heard from the parish council um that
there were concerns regarding
construction vehicles during the
construction phase etc
um we can see that the access to the
garages 20 garages is wide enough for
cars but
she certainly feared it wasn't wide
enough for refuse wagons and lorries and
the like
i know we wouldn't normally have a
construction management plan
when we're only dealing with
construction of three properties but
given the location
and the tightness of that access point
should we make an exception in this
regard and would it be reasonable to
request
a construction management plan as part
of the conditions please
i i see think in this instance it would
be reasonable to request
that yes just because of the issues
regarding access and
so forth to the area and come down
league present um
alice may be have further to that but i
don't think that would be
uh unreasonable or in unenforceable
yeah through you chairman i i completely
agree in this instance i think it would
be reasonable to condition a
construction management plan if members
are minded to do so
i think the only thing i would just like
to clarify cancel addiction you just
made reference to refuse vehicles
a construction management plan wouldn't
safeguard against that because we'd
expect them to bring bins to the edge of
the public highway so we just wanted to
clarify that
but certainly with regards to sort of
construction traffic vehicles delivery
that's certainly something which i think
would be reasonable to condition
thank you very much thank you chairman
fabulous thank you all for that so there
are no further questions of
clarification from officers
so let's go to debate who would like to
go first
councillor jennings
thank you chairman i've run through
these quite quickly
and there's no problem with highways and
it's already
there it's already used as a car park or
has been used to car parks cars can get
in and out of there
easily um instead of four it's now three
so it seems reasonable with the the
actual
size um good use of a redundant sight in
a built-up area
certainly enhances what's already there
complies with all the policies
i can see no reason why we shouldn't go
with the officer's decision
and grant and i'd like to propose that
fabulous document thank you very much
council jennings um
would you like to speak to it no i think
i'll
say i think council jennings is
completely right yeah uh good man i
completely agree with you as well i
think we've explored all the potential
uh issues um for this already and i
would wholeheartedly
second as well although that obviously
has already been done uh we do have
three more speakers so
i will uh call them in order so cancer
dixon first of all
thank you chairman i support the the
recommendation but i would like to see
a condition in respect of a construction
management plan
added so that we can have some control
over the development phase
and i would support i was and i would
want that otherwise i'd be inclined to
uh
go against the recommendation to be
honest
okay um understood you kind of put the
pressure on councillor jennings there
are you willing to accept that cancer
jennings a construction management plan
i am willing to accept that although you
could quite easily crane stuff in there
but
i'm happy to go along with the i'm happy
to go along with the construction
management plan
if ever if uh yeah yeah so without that
proposal
uh cancer kennel
good okay we'll add that to the
conditions um cancer
hencha seraphin please all right thank
you chair
i have concerns about these types of
developments
uh these these garage sites were built
for a reason many years ago
when there was actually less cars that's
the reason they were
built because there was no uh driveways
with the houses
um this only creates problems
and also i think even three on this site
is over development so i would against
go against the officers recommendations
thank you
thank you very much councillor
councillor fleming next please
yeah um i'd just like to say that i mean
this is we've had
three of these and as many of the last
few months in both in
bidford uneven and in ulster and other
similar places
um and to be fair you know they've all
gone through
um and in this instance i would have to
support the officer's recommendation
thank you marvelous
okay there being no more speakers i
think we can move to a vote we've had a
proposal
for granting uh which includes the
addition of a condition for construction
management plan
that has been seconded by councillor
kendall uh or myself whoever you want to
put down
um let's go for a vote councillor
richards four
thank you councillor fleming councillor
fleming for
that's the kendall councillor kendall
four
dickson catherine dixon for
hunter seraphin
i think you're on me account center of
him
sorry yeah excellencies everything
against
jennings council jennings four
and councillor males council mills four
six four and one against
thank you very much olivia that case uh
the committee therefore resolves to
grant application twenty zero one eight
five zero full
uh in line with office recommendation
but with the condition of
a traffic birth sorry construction
management condition
okay let's move to our next
item which is twenty zero
two three six eight out that is 29
london road on
in ships and
i'm getting some feedback at the moment
um if i could ask all speakers that have
logged in
to a mute their uh their phones
and b to uh to refrain from watching the
live stream whilst
uh we're on your item it does interfere
and it's slightly delayed you're best
off listening on your
your device um sorry i
i interrupted myself there so
application twenty zero two three six
eight out
uh 29 london road uh ships on stower our
case officer and presenting officers
paul thompson paul
whenever you're ready over to you thank
you chair
good evening councillors and good
evening ladies and gentlemen in the
audience
um you should in just a moment
see this which is
uh as the chair said this is 29
london road in chipset on stower it's a
site within the builder perry boundary
uh it's there are dwellings to the north
and
uh a fairly new cul-de-sac development
to the south as uh london road itself
at this part is a um a single
carriageway uh tree-lined
avenue this is an outline application so
this
site plan is only indicative the the the
layout and the landscaping and so forth
may all change before the houses get
built if they do
um we're looking at just the access so
if i
zoom into the front of the site there we
can see um the visibility display
in both directions um has an x distance
uh in line with the highways um
standards
and a y distance of 2.4 meters which
again
is normal that's uninterrupted in both
directions apart from
this tree here which is
a fairly hefty one and it looks a bit
like this
the highways engineer has
considered a road safety audit and
a response report which was submitted
with the application
which concluded collectively that the
um the loss of uh visibility for
of a car exiting the site for road users
on london road would be
a brief less than a second at the speed
limit
um and that this this risk if you put up
would be
acceptable uh it also showed that um
in the in the accident uh record there
is no
record of an accident taking place on
this stretch of the london road that
involved
um a car exiting from a site uh which
had a tree in the visitor display which
is as you can
see further down london road there is is
a fairly common
arrangement and that's that's all i have
to show on the presentation i will just
mention
um that there is on the update list
one um condition that we would need to
add
uh which is relates to um climate change
mitigation
methods which is a sort of new standard
condition that we'll be adding to
outline approvals
so again this is outline application
for the approval of the access and the
principle of development
my recommendation is to grant planning
permission
sorry my unmute button was having a bit
of a moment there
paul thank you very much for your
presentation uh just for members of the
committee and anyone
that may be watching council hench
seraphin has had to leave the
uh the meeting at this point for
personal reasons and we'll take no
further part i just want to make that
clear for anyone that is
observing let's move to our first uh
speaker
uh on this item which is councillor john
uh i hope i pronounced this right john
dinny
uh from shipston town council uh
councillor are you there can you hear us
you may need to press star and six to
unmute your phone
counselor denny hopefully you can hear
us
just to reiterate star and six will
unmute your
phone hello hello good evening
counselor denny yes that's correct um
i'm having a slight difficulty in that
you seem to be well behind
on what i'm looking at yeah i think i i
don't know if you heard my uh my comment
earlier on
the um the live speed is just marginally
delayed
so um you're better served listening to
us
uh prior to your your involvement on the
phone but then watching us afterwards on
the live stream
either way we you're here now which is
uh what we're interested in and uh we're
interested to hear what you've got to
say
so you have three minutes we'll give you
a 30 second warning whenever you're
ready please do start okay
uh thanks uh thank you chair and good
evening councillors and committee
members
thank you for the opportunity to speak
on behalf of ships and on star
and in support of objections from
neighboring properties
ships and town council rejects the
proposed outlying application
for the demolition of a bungalow an
erection of four two-story houses
one there's no need ships and has
substantially exceeded its household
housing allocation in the current local
plan and those are built
are not selling the density is too high
the houses are too big and will
overshadow overbear and overlook the
neighboring properties
including the tennis courts and the club
this site would be more suited to
single-story development
which is needed in the area lots of
trees while we acknowledge the
consideration given to tree retention
a considerable number of trees will be
lost the balance of biodiversity must be
enhanced not degraded
the flood risk ships and is incredibly
pleased to see the grant of eighty
thousand pounds by stratfor district
council for natural flood management
and you can rest assured this will be
put to good use by the shipston area
flood action group of volunteers
on the 17th of june this year both
wilkins clubs
and compton gardens which are listed as
precedent sites for this site
were inundated by flood water from the
a3400
with manhole covers raised and sewage
spilled
highways have recently cleared all the
drains on london road
but the pipe size is only 150
millimeters
and mr rogers of highways admits that
the
system can be overwhelmed by heavy
rainfall
that and but he says that this is for
seven trying to resolve
mr mccluster of several trent accepts
that two metre rise in the star at
shipston bridge
will close the flat valve on the storm
outflow at the bridge
this last happened on saturday the 5th
of december
during moderate rainfall periods of
heavy and sustained rainfall
are increasing in frequency and
intensity
so we should not add more hard area in a
sensitive neighborhood
should the committee decide to permit
the application then the building's
height and hard area must be reduced
more trees retained biodiversity
addressed
and surface water attenuated within the
site
including the expected overflow from the
3400
thank you chair
thank you very much for that very much
very well within your time members do we
have any questions
for our counsellor please indicate in
the chat if you do
i'm seeing very little action
i think that means there's no questions
counselor denny thank you very much as i
said before you'll be best served
continuing to watch now on the live
feed uh where you'll be able to uh to
see what
our deliberations and our discussions
but thank you again thank you very much
thank you okay our next speaker is mr
steve
bromley who is the agent on this
application mr bromley are you
there again if you press start on six
that will unmute your
phone to reiterate star
6 will unmute you
and hopefully we'll be able to hear you
mr bromley are you there are you able to
hear us
i can hear something in the background
but i don't hear a mr bromley
give another couple of seconds um i do
rather fortuitously
have a copy of mr bromley's
speech for this evening if we can't get
him i will read it on his behalf
mr bromley are you there can you hear us
please please press start on six to
unmute yourself
and hopefully we'll be able to hear you
i think we might have just lost mr
bromley
from the conversation so i propose to
read
for you all uh his submission so
here we go thank you chairman the
application is before you this evening
solely because of the objection of
ship's non-stop
sorry he's in the lobby now i think he's
in back in
okay we'll try again um and if we fail
this time i will continue to
read that uh mr bromley can you hear us
okay
i can disturbingly hear myself
i'll give it one more try mr bromley can
you hear us okay
if you could speak please we know you're
there
i think we will press on uh with
my reading out the um the proposed
submission so let me start from the
beginning
the application is before you this
evening solely because of the objection
of ships and star town council
therefore i will comment firstly on the
issues they have raised firstly the town
council question
the need for the proposed dwellings
stating that ships known star has
exceeded its housing allocation in the
local plan this is an issue members are
well versed in and has
arisen with many planning applications
the housing figures in the core strategy
are minimum growth figures not maximum
the proposals are for a net gain of only
three
dwellings regarding density of the
development
i refer members to the indicative layout
submitted with the application which
demonstrates a layout that achieves the
council's standards for garden sizes
separation distances and parking
standards are set out in the development
requirements spd compliance with these
standards will ensure a satisfactory
density of development
the application is for only four
dwellings and will be a density of
development comparable to other housing
schemes along london road
regarding trees submitted with the
application is a tree report which
confirms there are no
category a trees and identifies only two
cascari b trees neither of which will be
lodged
all other trees are category c trees of
low quality
suitable for replacement surface water
drainage is mentioned this is an outline
application and there will be plenty of
opportunity at reserve master stage to
include soft landscaping
permeable surfaces and drainage measures
to ensure
satisfactory surface water runoff rates
germany indica the indicative layout uh
demonstrates the site
offers the opportunity for a
well-designed housing scheme
in a layout very similar in character to
the pattern of development in the
immediate area
which is characterized by small
cul-de-sac developments
these include southland gardens the
north of the site and immediately to the
south of the site
seven houses at furlong meadow four
houses
at content gardens and six houses at
wilkins place
there are no objections from the
technical consultees including the
highway authority
wcc ecology or wcc fire and rescue i
asked the committee to support the
officer's recommendation and grant the
planning permission
that is verbatim what we have from mr
bromley it's a shame
he's not here and i'm afraid obviously i
can't ask questions
i'll answer any questions let me just
see if mr bromley is able to join us now
and ask any answer any questions if
indeed there aren't any mr bromley are
you there
if you're muted ah mr bromley
hello hello we're getting some slight
glitches
if you're running if you're watching the
live stream in the background if you can
turn it off
please perfect that sometimes has a bit
of a a problem with uh
with being able to hear our speakers but
clearly you you've beaten me to it
yeah you will have obviously have heard
that i have read out verbatim your
proposed
uh speech to save you going through it
again i think we'll move straight to
questions so if you just bear with me
when i see it
members do you have any questions for
the agent
i'll give you a couple of seconds
that looks like a no so mr bromley
apologies for
the uh the the trouble that you've had
with uh with technical and getting in
um we have read as i say verbatim your
speech
uh there are no questions so um if you
if you want to carry on watching the
live stream
please go ahead and do that yes thank
you chairman you read it out very well
thank you very much
i did my best thank you very much
we have no registered uh ward member for
tonight on this item so let's move to
clarification points for officers
do we have any points of clarification i
can see a few
no shaking heads at the moment
councilman mills has one
cancer mills thanks mr chairman um just
uh paul um on this density
uh question i mean okay
can you put our pawns on the plan
showing the the houses on this and see
what the density is for me please
uh yep that's on its way counselor um
whilst i'm doing that i would just
stress that layout
is for later approval so we can we can
address things like
this scale um the scale of development
so forth
uh here is
[Music]
the site plan which you should be able
to
see
[Music]
there now yep
okay
one two four four dwelling scans
yeah right okay i've got that
um thank you very much paul the next
thing is um
the parish the parish council council
raised the problem of um
flooding was it was a a flood risk
assessment
assessment done on this i can't see
anything
there wasn't um it doesn't fall within
um a flood risk area that
appears in environment agency data that
we have um
or that the applicant had for that
matter um i think
a lot of the issues that the parish
council
raises can certainly be addressed i
think as they themselves acknowledge in
their in their comments can be addressed
uh at the appropriate point in the
approval
process which would be uh sort of
landscaping reserve matters and or
building control okay lovely thank you
margaret thank you very much council
dixon
thank you chairman paul obviously uh
could could we
have a look at that picture please with
the tree i was wondering if we can
identify clearly on there where the
access to the site
is in respect of that street scene
that would be good for me
and whereabouts is the access to the
site is it immediately behind that
is it that yes oh yeah sorry yes it is
within the red circle there so it is
it is sort of the gap in the hedge that
you can you can just make out there
and that would obviously be adjusted
slightly
okay given given that the concerns
regarding sight lines
the fact that it's a highway tree if
there was a subsequent request
by the developer that the tree being
removed
and that was addressed to the county
council would they
the county council contact us for our
options to retain that tree or would it
be best if we want it
to protect it now with a tpo
um well alistair do you want to comment
on this one i know you were involved in
some
in some discussions on the matter
is that a planning issue
it is in as much as obviously the trees
there and it's acknowledged by
all the highway experts that there will
be an impact on visibility as a result
so because of that we can take it into
account and the other thing i would say
is that along
london road in shipston the avenue of
trees is a real characteristic so
we would not want to see that tree gone
basically
uh it contributes a lot to the area so
in that sense it does
fall within a planning matter the only
thing in terms of the question of
councillor dixon so that tree
is owned by county highways so
we would expect them to consider
the visual immunity value of those trees
before they agree for it to
to come out we would expect them to be
good stewards of those trees given
given the public community value we had
a very similar situation further down
london road and it wasn't considered
necessary to tpo the trees because of
they were
county highways trees rather than trees
owned by a developer who would
potentially benefit more
from that tree coming out and i think i
would just stress that i think as paul
said in the report
the the brevity of the breach and
visibility is
is so minor that yes there is a slight
uh impingement on that visibility
display
that county highways are satisfied that
it can that tree can be retained
and and sufficient visibility can be
afforded so as to make that access safe
so we'll just reiterate that
just don't want to lose the tree yeah i
completely agree yeah likewise
thank you very much all of you for that
uh council adam
thank you um it was just um
hopefully an easy one but looking at the
um your report
uh page 33 um you notice that
you you know the the concerns from the
town council are about the scale
of the development but then go on to say
that these matters would be
um for later approval as
in terms of outlying permission goes
i thought scale of the development on
large was
specifically what outline permissions
were therefore
and then scale of particular units
was was something that was concerned by
reserve matters
i mean that's just something that i sort
of
would like some clarity on and i've i've
struggled to find any documentation to
that effect either from
our our documents or from government on
planning
yeah there's i mean we're perhaps
talking about different things we talk
about
scale so i think you may be referring to
the amount of development which would be
the number of dwellings so in that case
that's
four that is that is something that is
uh
would be um approved in principle here
um in terms of the scale of the
individual units in terms
which is you know the the literal
dimensions of them that that is for
later approval that that would be
covered under the
um reserve matter of layout and
external appearance to some extent um so
there's
there's a a place for everything if you
like and everything in its place yeah i
mean
no that's what i was thinking but you
know on that basis it
it seems that the the town council's
concerns that you you appear to dismiss
in this paragraph seem seem to be more
relevant
than you make out is my point my
understanding council was that they were
concerned
chiefly and and certainly the the
neighbors who were concerned about
privacy and
and like well they're concerned about
where they're where they're they will be
positioned on the site
which would afford sort of sight lines
and so forth um they're concerned that
they're two stories opposed to single
story well
not nothing in this permission would
would
suspect would sort of set in stone that
these are going to be two-story
dwellings
nor that they're going to be in a
particular position on the site that
would harm privacy
and give us a bit of your view on that
as well please yes please thank you
chairman so
i i completely um concur with what what
paul's advising and would
reiterate that fully i think just in
terms of focusing the minds i think the
the outline is to establish the
principle so obviously the developers
applied for the four dwellings so if
members aren't satisfied that four
dwellings can be cited on the site then
that could potentially be a reason for
refusal
obviously the point that paul's making
is we don't know what the final design
is an officer's view
is that four dwellings could be designed
and
fit within the site to have acceptable
standards of immunity
and be in keeping with the character of
the area um but i just wanted to clarify
that point because it is
obviously a bit of a differentiation
between the principle and that scale
which is indeed a reserved matter
that's really useful thank you both for
your help on that thank you very helpful
yeah thank you alice
uh thank you paul as well um okay i can
see no more questions so who would like
to start us off in the debate
councillor jennings
thank you chairman and i think this one
is really simple
i mean four dwellings seems perfectly
adequate
in the size the plot this size um
and obviously the size of the houses
will be going to be determined at a
later date
i see no material planning reasons to go
against the officer's decision
therefore i'd like to propose that we
grant this application
good man thank you very much i will
second that um uh on the basis that
uh in the principle of the development i
have no particular issue with
any concerns that have been expressed i
believe can be dealt with at the reserve
matter stage
and given we have no uh objection from
our highways
um which it really is the access that
we're looking at predominantly
um i can see no reason to go again so i
will second that
um i can see cancer kendall and
councillor dixon have expressed their
interest in seconding but given we've
done that
uh let's move to a vote i will go first
council richards
four thank you councillor fleming
cancer fleming for answer kendall
councillor kendall four adam
fabulous in that case committee results
to grant application twenty zero two
three six
eight out twenty nine london road ships
and on star in line with the
officer's recommendation and the
additional condition on the update sheet
fabulous let's move to our next item
remember i'm conscious of the fact that
we have
about 40 minutes to get through this um
in order for us to be able to hear our
final one as well so again
please keep your questions and answers
concise i don't want to stifle debate
and discussion
but please keep it concise rather than
waffling so the application is 41 farm
street in harbory that's his application
number 202434
ful paul is our presenting officer yes
again paul whenever you're ready over to
you
thank you and i shall leap straight in
there this
should be appearing on your screen now i
think
[Music]
how about now yeah there we go okay so
this is farm street in harboury uh it's
within the conservation area
uh the nearest listed building is the
manor house which is some distance away
it's not uh within the second there's
also a listed building
uh up here a gable end neither of them
will be directly affected by the
development uh
the green circles are tree preservation
orders
there isn't one that applies to the site
but as all of the trees on the site are
within the conservation area they
receive protection in that respect
um you'll note on this plan the sort of
fairly varied
uh rhythm of development there's a
cul-de-sac development
uh to the north and uh some fairly
tightly packed houses to the south
and east what we have
is a fairly straightforward two-story
detached house
um again the the you'll notice the the
building line is
is slightly different um there but
given the variation in the street scene
and i'm not
taking that as a big issue um
what is a fairly large issue and
certainly was the last time we saw this
application which was early this year it
was withdrawn
um basically to to get some amendments
made
um the design of the uh the house has
changed
slightly just to bring in some features
that are typically the area looking at
the clipped the clipped eaves
and the dental course the dental
ventilated leaves course there
um the chief concern of
mine frankly and of neighbours and the
parish council
is the the trees particularly the trees
at the front of the site
now the biggest one is
both in terms of how much of a problem
it presents or and
and its size is t1
which is here
and also here
uh that will be removed but not
uh it's also this central tree here that
will be removed
not as a result of this development
though the the tree survey submit
alongside the development
is identified um using using both ground
level surveys and aerial surveys
has identified a fungal infection which
is basically going to
if left um dealt with
would bring the whole thing down into
the street which obviously we want to
avoid so that's coming down
anyway that the whatever decision
the councillors make this evening that
tree will have to
come down anyway t2
as identified in the application is this
slightly smaller
specimen of the same species just next
to it that's to be retained
um so also to be removed is g3
which is a group of trees here uh
another difference between this
application the previous version is that
that is going to be replaced like for
like these
trees are also unhealthy according to
the tree survey
and they're now going to be replaced
like for like so
in due course that street scene will be
replicated um here's
the fungal infection in question pretty
ugly as i'm sure you'll
agree um it's another picture of
g3 there and this is a view from the
rear which shows some of the other trees
to be removed
they're much smaller they're orchard
type trees
um they don't make much of a
contribution to this the street scene
one exception is is t3 which is
uh about there in the picture um it's a
little bit larger and it although it's
not
directly visible um certainly in summer
it does
contribute some depth to the foliage if
you like
um that's going to be replaced if you
just see here
with another tree which will
hopefully replicate that contribution to
the street scene
again this is within the build superior
boundary
so residential development is acceptable
in principle
um given the changes to the screen at
the
scheme since the last submission i
consider it acceptable i recommended
that we grant planning permission
thank you
i know i don't know why but my mute
button is playing silly beggars tonight
and it's gone on and off and on and off
when i'm not clicking it anyway you've
got me now let's move paul thank you
very much
let's move to our first speaker who is
counselor alan from harboury parish
council
council alan are you there can you hear
me you may need to press start
six to unmute yourself start
six will unmute you
i can hear some rustling i can't hear a
voice counselor alan
are you there
counselor alan i'll give you another
couple of seconds otherwise i also have
your
speech tonight and i will read that too
counselor alan are you there
i'm going to take that as a no
hopefully allen can join us shortly
um but in the meantime in the interim i
will attempt
to read harvard parish council's meeting
notes excuse me when i bring it up right
okay
so the parish council arbi crash council
would like to say as
an integral and important position in
one of our two conservation areas with
mature trees
tree frontage and surrounded listed
buildings
this is a sensitive plot in harbory we
appreciate that the applicant has
included some mitigation measures in the
application
and we would like to ask for the
following to be considered as planning
conditions in the event
you seek to grant permission in this
instance
at the front of the plot are two mature
ash trees t1
and t3 which impede access to this
development
we understand that there is an
alternative reason to move t1
due to its current condition with the
proposed
removal of this mature tree from our
conservation area we would ask
that if there is a failure to t2 then
you would add a condition
that this should be replaced with an
equivalent tree
type within a 12-month period in order
to maintain
the future street scene the loss of one
mature tree is disappointing the loss of
a second would be exceptionally
visually damaging the applicant intends
to plant a white beam in the vicinity
of t2 to partially mitigate the loss of
t1
we would request a condition that this
is planted before occupation
to ensure continued highway safety we
would also request a condition that the
entrance remains
ungated that is the end of crash council
comments i'm very quickly going to see
if
councillor alan has been able to rejoin
us counselor alan are you there
i am sorry we've got you we're having
all sorts of technical issues tonight um
so i don't think it's isolated to you um
you'll be pleased to hear
you have probably just heard that i've
read your speech out
um i don't propose to ask you to reread
it for us
uh but if you can hang on while i ask if
our members have any questions for you
uh then we can let you go so members do
you have any questions there's a few
shaking heads
i judging from that there is um there
are no questions so council and thank
you for
for joining us and your patience in
getting into the meeting um
you're probably best served to continue
watching online uh through the live feed
and hanging out with your phone now but
thank you for joining us
okay great thank you bye thanks okay
our applicant sorry our agent is our
next speaker mr roy hammond mr hammond
are you there can you hear me okay
you may need to press star on six to
unmute yourself
mr hammond can you hear me
oh i think we've got you hello
yes mr hammond this is joyous news
you're the first speaker that's managed
to join on time
we're sorry not on time but join and be
heard uh in time to speak so
you have three minutes whenever you're
ready please start we'll give you a 30
second warning before the end
but over to you thank you good evening
chairman and councillors i'm roy hammond
and i speak on behalf of the applicant
in sport in sport
uh and as always thank you for allowing
me the opportunity
to speak the office's recommendation for
approval is noted
and welcomed uh we have certainly worked
hard to achieve an acceptable scheme
and are grateful to the council the
officer for their proactive approach
the merits of the proposal are clearly
and concisely set out in the office's
report
but there are some key merits that i
would just like to highlight to members
the proposed dwelling would be
constructed on the site within the built
up area boundary
of the village which is a category one
service
village where such development is
regarded as
as acceptable in principle the proposal
would develop
underused land in a settlement which is
consistent with national planning policy
which guides councils to give great
weight to such proposals
highlighting the important contribution
that small windfall development can make
to housing delivery
the officer's comments on the council's
housing numbers are noted
and i would reiterate that they do not
present a maximum
the application is supported by a robust
or a cultural report confirming that the
tree on the frontage needs to be removed
irrespective of whether the development
goes ahead or not
the adjacent ash tree would be
safeguarded
and i note the parish council's comments
there is there should be no reason to
believe that it would be
would be lost uh we're also proposing to
replace a row
a row of ivy choked end of life hall
forms
uh on a like for life but like for like
basis
and also proposing a suitable
replacement for t3
uh within the front garden of the plot
overall the proposal replacement trees
which would at worst rather preserve the
character of the conservation area but
more likely
enhance its significance the proposal
follows the pattern of existing
development along farm street
and is of an appropriate scale and form
and responding positively to the
the design of historic vernacular
buildings and the locality
existing and future residential immunity
would be safeguarded through adequate
separation
due regard to the sighting of
neighbouring dwellings and through
provision of adequate
amenity space one matter not mentioned
in the officers report is a recent
appeal decision relating to a proposed
dwelling
on a frontage site for short
in farm street which presented very
similar issues to the proposed
including tree loss and arguably on a
more constrained and more sensitive site
that appeal was allowed so that
concludes my
presentation thank you for your time and
i i do hope
that the members and planning committee
are able to support the proposal
thank you mr hammond thank you very much
uh members do we have any questions for
mr hammond's seeing some shaking heads
i'm going to give you a
couple of seconds anyone that wants to
type
nope okay mr hammond you've covered all
bases so thank you very much for your
contributions this evening
uh your best place to watch our live
stream so if you want to hang out now
and continue to watch that'll be great
but thank you again for your
contributions
okay uh we have no ward member
registered
this evening so we will move to uh
clarification of points from our
officers members do you have any points
for clarification any questions comes to
kendall
first thank you chairman uh just a quick
question the parish council mentioned
a number of requests in terms of
conditions um
how would officers feel about those if
those were added
yeah happy with that they're actually um
the no gates condition is in the list of
draft conditions
um the replacement of t2 would be a
standard requirement of the um hard and
soft landscaping scheme condition
the wording is uh usually something on
the lines of
any failures due to disease uprooting
death whatever else must be replaced in
the
next planting season their next
available planting season
after the the failure so yeah but both
of those issues are
are covered understandable i think one
of the questions from the
would it be possible to plant that tree
prior to occupation of the building
unless i'm misunderstanding that there
is a um
a replacement tree that is on is in the
landscape scheme which will be that will
be part of the um
again it would need to be implemented it
wouldn't be before occupation because
that would
potentially require it to be planted
during
outside of planting season which would
obviously not be particularly favorable
for it but certainly
it would be the same wording so in other
words within the first planting season
at the first available planting season
that way that's
not satisfied that's fine i'm happy with
that thank you yeah good question
stanley
um council mills uh mr
morris is same as uh council kendall so
i'll pass on that one thank you
okay no problem at all um i can see no
further questions for our officer
so let's move to the debate who would
like to kick us off
who's the quickest typer councillor
jennings is
seem to be hogging these um okay i've
run through it really quickly
extensive liaisons with the officer has
resolved most of the issues well all the
issues as far as i can see
t1 has to come down um t2 will have a
better chance of survival
um and the new tree at the back ecology
is fine
highway is okay it's a win foresight
therefore i'd like to propose
to go along with the officer's
recommendation and grant this
application
good man thank you very much cancer
jennings uh councillor kendall had
initially suggested he wants to propose
i'm going to assume yeah i can see it
now
yep perfect thank you very much there
being no one else wishing to speak
i'm assuming no good let's move to a
vote so the vote
is all the pros is the grant in line
with officer recommendation council
richards four
thank you councillor fleming councillor
fleming for
and um councillor kendall four
councillor adam four chancellor dickson
councillor dixon for jennings
councillor jennings ford and councillor
miles councilwoods4
fabulous thank you very much olivia so
uh committee therefore resolves to grant
application twenty
zero two four three four ful 44 on farm
street
in harbory in line with the officer's
recommendation
i don't know why i was concerned that we
might not have time for our last one
because we have flown through that
thank you very much members and officers
our final application for the evening is
twenty zero two six six one ful that's
green acres middle lane newbold on
stower our presenting officer is joe
brook
joe whenever you are ready please do
commence
thank you chair let me just start the
presentation again uh i'll take it
everybody can see that
certainly can great
so let me just start
the site is located when the physical
confines of newbold onstar as indicated
by the black dot before you
the application is seeking planning
permission to demolish the existing
dwelling green acres and construct fire
dwellings within the application
site as indicated by the red line
boundary
two of the dwelling houses would be
sighted directly from onto mill lane
and a third of three dwellings will be
located to rear which is currently the
rear garden of green acres
the proposed dwellings are all set at
two stories high with attached garages
either to the side
for plots one two three or to the front
projection for plots
four and five
plots three four and five represent
architectural detailing with large gaze
apertures
timber boarding with modest fenestration
uh
windows and wooden doors or plots one
and two which is front
of mill lane as indicated by the plan
for you is proposing a two-story design
with simple fenestration detailing
as indicated in the officers report
so this is plot five uh it's a larger
the largest of the proposed dwellings
and it gives you a good indication of
the design and proposal
um large apertures
usual pony paint windows wooden doors so
forth
this is site sections of the properties
so
this one will be looking up towards mill
lane because that is the development of
the thirds which is currently under
construction
so this is plot two then plot three plot
one and two sorry then part three and
then plot five
this is from the other side so you can
see orca drive
uh outline of orca drive which is a
neighboring dwelling that's plot four
plot two this is photos of the front of
green acres as it is
so you see it's quite a long extenuated
single story design
um this is the other side you can see
the very application
which is taking place at the minute with
the furs and also developments to the
north
and this is neighboring property orc
drive
this is the application sites the green
acres would obviously be demolished
um this is orca drive and this is the
large garden area it is where the
number three dwellings will be located
within
this is mill lane itself that is looking
towards the bottom of mill lane
the properties down there and that is
looking upwards you can see construction
is going on for the dwellings to the
north
this is the neighboring property
directly the third which is currently
under construction
so the properties and proposals would be
here in the view line
this is awkward drive that's green acres
at the minute which is the exact
neighborhood property
and this is mill lane itself when
looking downwards as you can see the
properties to
on mill lane and facing onto main
highway
have already been built and there is
some of the construction to area
that's the end of the presentation um
in consideration the area's development
plan national policy and guidance as
well as the relevant statutory
consultations
the officer's recommendation on planning
balance is approval subjected
to recommendations i sat out in the
report there are no updates thank you
chad
joe thank you very much um we will go
straight to our speakers we have no
parish or
town council registered so our first
speaker is dr stella khan
dr khan can you hear me
you may need to press start and six to
unmute yourself
stop to khan are you able to hear me
gosh we're having a torrid time with
speakers tonight aren't we
i don't i think that's probably our ah
dr khan i can hear you
yeah hi there i can't tell you how much
of a relief it is to be able to hear
something
okay i don't know if you've done this
before but to just to let you know
you've got three minutes
um we'll give you a 30 second warning
before uh your time
uh ends and if you can send the line
after us for any questions that would be
great but whenever you're ready please
please do start okay thank you very much
i thank the committee members for
allowing me to speak and hope these
concerns are taken into account when
coming to your decision
firstly urbanization effect of mill lane
although it is argued that mill lane has
already been urbanized by the 35 house
kendrick development
the lower half of mill lane is a private
single country lane
which currently has only six dwellings
situated in large grounds
adjacent to open farmland the
demolishing of the existing house
in order to squeeze in five
double-storey houses
with double garages completely alters
this rural nature
and changes it to that of a mini housing
estate
secondly a substantial increase in
traffic on mill lane
as previously mentioned this is a
private single country lane
with the lowest section from green acres
down to the mill
being privately owned by the existing
six properties
to increase the traffic load by 15 cars
as well as visitors
services deliveries etc would cause
congestion delays
and safety issues in particular for
pedestrians and children
moreover increased flooding risk to
three homes at the bottom of mill lane
the green acres application states that
the development will not
pose an increased flooding risk
elsewhere we disagree
as evidenced already from kendrick's
ongoing development
we are now being flooded at a 0.5 metre
lower level
of the river sour due to a substantial
increase in runoff water that gushes
down mill lane
we were last flooded christmas 2019 and
on a yearly basis we prepare for floods
the proposed addition of passing points
not only
ruins the rural nature but will most
certainly exacerbate our risk of
flooding
and finally unacceptable disruption
residents on mill lane have had to
endure
two years of heavy-duty vehicles and
numerous cars blocking access
to and from our homes this is
unacceptable given that we are given no
warning
and many of us have work school and
other commitments
including hospital on-call covert 19
duties
communicating directly with contractors
is both frustrating and pointless
we certainly have reason to be concerned
with green acres developers
given the recent display of inaction in
response to a water leak in their
grounds
that is still continuing after three
months
due to our continual badgering of seven
trent
we believe a section 75 notice has been
issued
issued and some not only if there's an
environmental concern given the large
loss of water
but it has caused a mud bath outside our
homes at the bottom of mill lane
and when frozen is hazardous and the
loss of tarmac has left behind potholes
for us
residents to foot the bill i thank you
for your time
das khan thank you very much just within
your time ideal members do we have any
questions for dr khan
maybe a couple of seconds to write in
the chat if you do
so looks like there are no questions so
thank you very much for your
contribution this evening um as with all
other speakers you'll be best served
watching this
the live stream um rather than listening
on your phone so
if you want to hang out now you can um
thank you again
thank you bye okay
our next uh speakers are our applicant
an
agent sorry forgive me agent and uh
transport planning consultants we have
uh jane cashmore
agent and simon and parfit our transport
planning consultants or the agents
uh planning consultants are you both
there
i'm sure yes hello thank you
a wonderful day to hear someone coming
through again
um jane how do you propose to split your
time are you going to do the full three
minutes and and simon's here for
questions or are you going to split it
um we're going to split it roughly half
and half so simon i'll just follow on
straight after me
you don't need a half a 1 minute 30
warning
no we'll be fine thank you okay no
problem in that case whenever you're
ready
okay thank you good evening councillors
this is a revised application to that
refused in july by committee b
that application had officer support and
during committee the council solicitor
strongly discouraged members pursuing
highways and housing numbers reasons for
refusal
the housing numbers point is clear
policy does not set a maximum figure and
there is no evidence to suggest four
additional dwellings in newbold would be
detrimental to local infrastructure
with regards to design slides one and
two on the screen
show examples of the applicant's
developments the design of the proposed
dwellings is similar to these which have
been found
acceptable elsewhere in the district
since the refusal the applicant asked a
local chartered member of the landscape
institute
john bailey to review impacts on the
landscape character of the area and
design
his report has been submitted he states
that
introducing two-story stone-faced
detached homes of high-quality design on
the green acre site would be wholly
appropriate
would enhance sense of place and cause
no undue harm to the street scene
he goes on to say in relation to the
development of the garden and i quote
the land of the kendrick home site has
been granted approval for housing
development
even though it was open so to claim that
undue harm would be caused by the loss
of a comparatively small plot of open
land on the green acres site
would be inconsistent and unreasonable
the kendrick home site
is under development on slide three
there would be no harmful urbanization
and i quote
the site has been all but surrounded in
housing development such the
urbanization of the land on the north
northeast side of mill lane either
southern fringe of the village has
already taken place
i'll now leave simon to cover highways
good evening i hope you can hear me okay
my name is simon parfitter and i'm a
director at david tucker associates
who are a local specialist transport
planning consultancy
following the previous committee the
applicant commissioned the detailed
topographical survey
of the a3400 in the area to prove the
visibility displays are deliverable
we have demonstrated that based on the
recorded speed of traffic
and applying the relevant guidance for
local roads the displays can be
delivered
we've also shown on the plan which you
will see on slide four on the screen
the new section of footwear and the
passing areas on mill lane
which have been requested by the county
and will not only cater for the proposed
development
but also be beneficial to existing
residents of mill lane
again this is based on survey
information to prove they are
deliverable the previous committee much
was made about a 2015 application
where the county objected to development
on mill lane however that response was
based on design standards
only applicable to trunk roads such as
the a46
did not apply here the county have fully
considered the current application
they have no objections and have clearly
stated that the junction has operated
safely
for as far back as their records go due
to the minor increase in traffic
forecast to use mill lane
the impact of the development cannot be
considered severe
and the development fully complies with
the requirements to set out in the mppf
thank you very much for listening thank
you very
much both for your contributions uh if
you just hold on the line for a second i
see if anyone wants to ask you a
question members
maybe to you please indicate in the chat
if you would like to ask a question
you have a couple of seconds
i can see no one desperately diving at
all counselor adam came in at last
minute cancer adam
thank you um hopefully it'll be a
relatively simple one
um part of the major concerns by the
residents that were raised
uh related to flooding have you uh and i
appreciate it
that the site is in flood zone one but
obviously being directly adjacent to
the river which is flood zone three i
can see why they've got concerns
have you um investigated the impact that
this development might have
on that and so we haven't carried out a
flood risk assessment because
there is no requirement to do so on a
site which is in flood zone one and of
this size
the applicants are proposing to
discharge surface water
via soakaways subject to ground
conditions um
so other than that i have no more
information on that on drainage
okay thank you very much
lovely thank you very much council adam
there being no other questions
um thank you very much both jane and
simon for your contributions this
evening again if you want to follow on
the live stream you'll be best placed to
do that and you can hang up your phones
now so thank you again
thank you thank you very much take care
bye marvelous okay we now have
our final speaker of the evening uh
councillor harvey who has been
immensely patient while we work our way
through the
agenda council harvey you've got five
minutes we'll give you a 30 second
warning whenever you're ready it's over
to you
thank you very much chairman some of us
have been here before in relation to
this application
although there have been some minor
adjustments to the original application
that was refused by the relevant
committee in july this year
this new application is changed by the
barest amount to avoid it being ruled
out
as merely the resubmission of the
previous application
it remains what it always was a proposal
to demolish an existing dwelling
set in a large rural garden and to
replace it with five substantial houses
on a new service road and yet the
essential facts remain unchanged
mill lane was originally laid as a track
providing access to the mill on the
river
star and to the surrounding farmland
mill lane is a single track road
with no turning circle its obvious
limitations to cope with additional
volumes of traffic
were recognized by the decision for the
35 homes development by kendricks at the
top of mill lane
in that instance permission was granted
on the basis that there would be no
access for traffic from
any of those 35 houses onto mill lane
for the simple reason it couldn't cope
and yet the traffic generated by the
proposed five houses
each with the provision for parking
three cars
will effectively double the volume of
traffic in mill lane
similarly the questionable safety of the
junction of mill lane with the stratford
road was the basis of the highway
authority's objection to
and a prime factor for the refusal of an
application in 2015
for a similar development of five new
substantial houses
at the exchange in mill lane and yet
since the previous application was
refused there have been no alterations
to this junction
the highway authority has made no
changes to the layout the hedges that
restrict the driver's view of this
junction
are still where they always were and the
junction still lies
in a 60 miles per hour zone the issue at
stake remains
the safety of the public in using this
junction
i've pointed to the decision of the
stratfor planning committee to refuse an
application on the exchange in
2015 in large measure because of highway
authority's expert view
that required visibility displays could
not be achieved
nothing has changed in defeating in the
intervening period
on a different interpretation of the
same junction however
the developers paid highways consultant
has drawn
a different conclusion i'm not a
highways expert
and i shall have to leave it to you to
decide the finer points
of where the splay line should be
measured to the center of the road
or to the near side of the carriageway
or whether undulations in the road are
required to be taken into account
what i can say is that when this matter
was raised with the previous committee
it was concluded that it merited one of
the reasons for
for the refusal of that application
because it would quote
cause undue harm to the existing highway
network
on my understanding it still would
i set out in my original submissions for
the planning reasons why i think this
application
conflicts with the requirements of cs 9
15 and 16.
the case officer again takes a different
view as he's entitled to do
but at least this illustrates an honest
difference of opinion based on a
different subjective
evaluation the residents of newborn take
the view
that this application should again be
refused because the village has already
taken
a higher proportion of new dwellings in
relation to cs16
than all but five settlements in the
entire district
the committee that dealt with the
previous application accepted this point
and i invite the committee to be
consistent in its decision making
the developer makes much of the fact
that green acres lies with newbold's
proposed
built up area boundary there is nothing
automatic about development being
permitted within
a built-up area boundary applications
have been refused before now
within such boundaries in this instance
the committee has the opportunity to
decide
that it wishes on sound planning grounds
to retain mill lane
as part of the rural fringe of newbold
rather than to provide another example
of unmitigated
urban creep finally can i point to the
ultimate irony about this application
there's been a long-standing shortage
across the stratford district
of both one-bedroom units and bungalows
if this council is to play any
meaningful part
in place shaping it would be completely
incongruous
for this committee to grant an
application that involved the gratuitous
demolition of a bungalow thank you mr
chairman
thank you very much for that uh members
do we have any questions for our ward
member
indicating the chat if you do
[Applause]
i can see no movement and no excitement
about questions so
um castle harvey thank you very much uh
we will move on
to our points of clarification for
officers uh members do you have any
points
to clarify sorry chad just before you do
that i have to highlight that the um
agent did submit a presentation which
just crashed on me so i think i should
probably show the four slides that she
was referring to
understood yes please do absolutely fine
let me share the screen my pause is over
start slide number one of developments
carried out but in wooden stratfor
district
examples of other developments by the
applicant
that's side three which shows the
developments going on as referred to by
the agent
and the long mill lane and that is slide
for which you briefly saw
sadly when the presentation finally uh
come back to a live
in which the harleyware's expert was
referring to
understood joe thank you very much for
that i appreciate it
we have points of clarification now so
could you indicate the chat if you'd
like to ask a question
to joe to our officers
i'm gonna take that as a no oh
cancer jennings
thank you chairman sorry on that very
last slide we should just shown
is it have they expanded the mill lane
to
incorporate so you can get more than one
car down there insert or turn
past it not as such so let me show you
the photo again so you got a good
um indication
so no not really that's where they're
proposing new passing areas which
highways are recommended
um for going down mill lane this is the
area where the new development's taking
place right now
with a lot of developments already took
on so
fundamentally know that the past
invasion should be able to provide the
access and that's why highways have
offered no objection
okay thank you thank you guys
and councillor dixon has one for you as
well please counsel dixon thank you
chairman
could we see the uh photograph that you
had within your own presentation joe
please
and show the sign for middle lane and
the vehicle part
perhaps 30 yards down the lane
yeah i think i know which one you're
referring to uh just just in case just
tell me if i'm the wrong one but
i think you'll have the right one i'm
sure
is it that one character no i think it
was a was it
i have an idea it was on the other side
of the road that one
that's the one now in your opinion joe
if a tractor wanted to get past those
vehicles could it do so
the honest truth is currency is that i i
have to go back to what
the highways experts are stating and
we've in the previous application we've
had this quite in-depth
discussion over it so it's all publicly
available
um the highways officer has adamantly
told me that there is no
accidents or injuries down that area
and also you've got to consider that the
likes of refuse vehicles and also
tractors and that lot
how often would they be therefore going
up and down
that small lane where that would become
a major issue
and so we have had them discussions and
i i'm not going to sit here and say for
certain whether a tractor could go by
that or not i don't know
that's construction work that's going on
right at this moment in time
all i can say is highways have offered
no objection and we have raised them
issues with highways
and they still offer no objection
thank you very much joe um are there any
further questions and points for clarify
clarification from our offices i see
nothing in our meeting chat
i'm going to give you 10 seconds to do
to type in there if you have a question
otherwise we will move on
it's only the fastest 10 seconds ever
because i can't see anyone typing so
let's move on uh open up for debate who
would like to kick us off
should i call on councillor jennings
because he's had such great form of
doing that
tonight oh there he is council jennings
i'm going to let someone else go first
council jennings given no one else has
indicated they want to speak and you
have i would suggest that you kick us
off
please
i think tony dixon's okay cancer dixon
can come in now then
thank you very much councillor jennings
no problem at all i do have concerns
regarding this uh this lane
now it may be that rules and regulations
have changed but certainly i can
remember a development
site uh in tanworth where
okay that was described as backland
development but the highways had
a limit on the number of properties that
could access
the site through a small single
and access driveway an idea it was
either five or six it wasn't very many
and certainly that development had to be
restricted because
of that specific reason but i am going
back
perhaps 15 or so years things might have
changed
but certainly i do have concerns
regarding access to this
and equally well i do know of a
situation in my own parish
whereby planning permission was granted
with sight lines which were approved
when it was developed the sight lines
could not be maintained
it went to enforcement who asked the
county council
what the situation was in the council
count county council said
the sight lines have not been achieved
but they're near enough not to warrant
actually taking any action
so no action was taken so i'm just
wondering how much reliance
we can place upon highways
thank you councillor dixon are you
making a proposal to uh
to refuse the application or are you
just making comments at this stage
at this stage i'm making comments i'd be
prepared to happy to listen to everybody
else but i'm
i'm not minded at the present time to be
very supportive of the application
okay understood um counselor kendall
has come in for a comment cancer can't
let you
thank you chairman um i'm getting
increasingly concerned about this
application um
i'm looking for planning material
planning grounds i understand the
committee don't like it and i
don't like it particularly but
the applicants have come back with a
modified proposal
one less house and i'm concerned
that i'm not seeing enough planning
grounds to
go against this and i'm minded that if
we end up in a position of going to
appeal
that's going to cost the council money
uh we've got no objection from count
from highways
and that's that's really bothering me so
right now i'm leaning
unhappily towards going with the
officer's recommendation
but i notice alice would like to clarify
something
uh alice has indicated that she would
like to clarify something so alice would
you like to come in now please
yes thank you i think ross has just
picked up on chat as well
um just i just wanted to clarify that
it's not one less house so it's the same
number of houses proposed as last time
so i don't know whether it's because it
was it was five before but that didn't
include the demolish
demolition i'm sorry i missed counting
but no don't worry i just wanted to make
sure that that we're not making any
decisions
no worries thank you councillor what i
said
i think uh i'm still concerned though
that we're you know we've not got
planning
material planning reasons to go against
us and my concern as i said earlier
is really about the um possibility of an
appeal
uh council candle is understood and
thank you i would divert your attention
to page 51 which i think
lists five reasons the um application
was refused in july
i wonder whether you put you could put
thought to those and whether they still
apply
uh i'll leave you to do that while i
call councillor jennings back in who had
indicated to speak and see if he's ready
to go
thank you chairman yeah it's one of
these ones where
i don't like it but again just because i
don't like it
doesn't mean that i can go against i'd
have to have very good reasons to go
against the officer's
uh recommendations
we can't say that we would
we'd refuse this simply because there
might be a traffic accident
at some point in the future it's sort of
i mean that's simply just you can't you
can't do that
um but i am
i'm i'm trying to find reasons at the
moment but
i say i'm struggling uh
for valid planning reasons
rather than just being what i like or
don't like
so i'm i'm i'm still going over this
again
okay that's understood counselor adam
has indicated a wish to speak counselor
adam
thank you i mean i think there's this
clear
sense of feeling around this um despite
the fact that it is difficult and
i think the amount of work that has been
put in by the officers is
you know notable um in in trying to make
this a sort of a workable scheme
that said um as you mentioned on page 51
there are five reasons
um the previous scheme was refused
i going through them now i think they
stand up and you'll be
you won't be surprised to know that the
first of which being
uh cs16 is one that i feel very strongly
about that over development
is uh this thing that we should be able
to um
control on that basis um it may
take me a little while to get my wording
together together
but on that basis i am happy to propose
that we go against the officer's
recommendation and
refuse the application okay council adam
thank you very much
um there is no one else indicating to
speak at this point so i'll just try and
surmise
the general sense of feeling i'm getting
is that uh members are inclined to
refuse but the question is
what grounds we're looking to refuse on
um cancer adam has has
referred as i did to page 51 and the
reasons that were
set out in the previous decision
um he's already referred to uh
to cs16 the first bullet point
i wonder if you're inclined
to think that those are appropriate
reasons to refuse
i can understand i if it were me i would
certainly be removing the architectural
detailing design i don't think there's
any particular
issue with the architectural detailing
design at this stage so i'd remove
that as a reason
i'm not entirely convinced that uh the
bullet point
four as it is in front of you is
relevant but you may be able
you may decide otherwise
the visibility displays is a concern um
and it wouldn't be the first time we've
gone against our highways officers
we are in we are in indeed it is within
our gift
to be able to go against the highways
guidance
they don't always get it right um we
have it we have indeed and i i sat on a
committee
who went against guidance from our
highways and indeed that decision was
upheld at an appeal
so we have uh we have history of being
able to
defend those decisions but they do need
to be sound and robust
i think that's all i can do really in
terms of surmising where we're at
we need to come to a decision we do need
to propose sorry we do need reasons to
support the proposal
that counselor adam has made counselor
adam having
counselor kendall has indicated his wish
to comment i'll ask him to come in first
and then we'll go back to counselor adam
uh to see if he's had a chance to get
his words together so cancer kendall
thank you chairman um i'm looking
through those but the reasons that we
used last time
i think i think i could agree with the
first bullet point
and the final bullet point the other
three i'm not
i'm not comfortable with would counsel
adam would he take that on board
cancer adam yeah i'd be perfectly
willing
to take that on board i'm going through
them in more detail now and i think
that those are reasonable comments um
[Music]
yeah i i may be inclined to include
number two but yes yeah i think
those are still reasonable enough
grounds as suggested by councillor
kendall to
um back my proposal in paddling in the
planning balance
okay so i think actually having reread
now
the um second third and fourth bullet
points i'm inclined to agree with cancer
kendall
um that only really bullet point one and
bullet point five
are strong reasons for to refuse
i'm in two minds over bullet point one
but i've got no issue if you want to
include that
um if we're happy with those two as our
reasons
um i'm happy to move forward and seek a
seconder before i do that i just want to
get our legal officer to come in and and
give his view on on things as they stand
now so ross can you come in and give
your point of view please
yeah i mean ironically i think bullet
points one and five are quite concerning
there's reasons for refusal which was my
advice back in july
um bullet point one it's about the
um it's about how
the approximate housing numbers isn't it
and um i think appeal decisions have
always said you need to identify sort of
planning harms
um you know it refers to
constraints on local infrastructure and
services but sort of where's the
evidence there of planning
of any planning harm similarly bullet
point five comes down to evidence as
well you're going against highways
advice so you know you can go against
highways advice but you need
a robust case you need evidence um
to go against the professional opinion
of highways so i would just sort of
sound a no of concern in relation to
bullet points one and five which is um
what i did back in the summer
okay that's good to be consistent thank
you um i guess it's good for us to be
consistent as well
uh let's uh calling counselor jennings
who's indicated he wished to speak
earlier on council jennings yes
i was just looking through looking
through the those five points
and i'm i'm struggling
i'm struggling on on all of them to be
honest
um i wish there was
another i wish there was another reason
so at the moment as much as i don't like
this
i'm struggling against going on going
against the officer's decision i'm
afraid
okay uh councillor dixon has indicated a
wish to comment councillor dixon you
wanna come in now
thank you chairman yes i quite like
bullet point
four as the harm that the increase in
the urbanization etc
essentially you know i'm thinking that
when you approach
this uh along the a3400 and you're
seeing
that development going beyond the
existing development the
new build going further out if you like
to the north east
into the countryside it is extending the
urban
approach to the newborn on star i
perceive
and as such i would regard bullet point
three
as also not bullet points three bullet
point four reason
has been an acceptable reason when
linked to
bullet point one i.e it is the harm
that's being caused by this extra
housing
okay thank you very much cancer kendall
i'm going to call him for a comment now
before councillor adam
councillor kendall
i'll take you on board ross's advice
i'm going to go back to what i said
earlier i i'm struggling
now i know i made a suggestion for
bullet point one five
largely because i i didn't see any any
benefit in the other three
that was the only two i liked but uh i
i've got i'm
listening to ross he makes a fair point
as well so
i'm still very much on the fence and i'm
struggling
finding the the material planning ground
so we've got to be so
clear on this uh council jennings is
you know i don't know if he's edging
towards making a couch proposal
i wonder yes i wonder indeed let's um
let's call it i know cancer fleming
you've um
put in a comment i don't know if you
wanted to speak to your comments or not
if it was
just a comment it was really just a
comment and
looking at the uh the five cases we we
refused on before
and i think three and four were probably
weaker than the others
but i just wonder whether the others are
strong enough to win through again you
know
and strong enough to go back and
especially going against
uh county officers county uh engineers
yeah understood um counselor adam do you
want to come in at this point
yeah i think so i'm trying to digest
this um as
best as possible i mean going through it
i think the i'm trying to find the the
key phrases within this which jump
out to me in each in each of the the
sort of five points
i think it's fair to say that the third
isn't particularly relevant given the
sort of architectural aspect of it
i think looking at say the second one uh
the final sentence is that
um in relation to a significant increase
in traffic and urbanization of the site
and i do think that that can be
considered
as i think it was pastor dixon mentioned
it it's
it would be in addition to other
developments in the area
and also on point number four uh
and you harm to the local landscape by
creating a
significant level of urbanization i mean
again i think that is relevant
um which would essentially pull them
into play in my mind
now when considering that i think that
summating those four points um
emitting number three in terms of
planning balance
offers enough grounds to
go against the officer's recommendation
but it would rely on
those together to to justify that
so in a nutshell you're saying the
cumulative effects of these things
uh are um sufficient in your planning
in your in you balancing the planning
merits um
to refuse is what you're saying i'd say
so yeah
yeah okay understood um
before i start before i start to talk
about that
i just want to ask about uh ross
would you be more comfortable with
a um possibly a single maybe two
uh reasons for refusal as
uh just outlined by councillor adam and
the cumulative effect of those being our
reason to refuse
yeah i'm not sure it's about me being
comfortable
it's very much for members it's just my
my advice is that i think
um reasons for refusal that go against
highways officers advice need to be
robust and based on
evidence and i also think the housing
numbers reason has been
considered many times appeal and
inspectors have said you very much have
to look at the planning harms that arise
and whether there are any or not and i'm
not sure any have been identified in
relation to the addition of
this number of houses okay understood
um let me just very quickly uh talk uh
to cancer adam's suggestions here so
first of all bullet point two talks
about
and we bear in mind there are other we
we could
uh develop other reasons to refuse
rather than just focusing on those five
so if you want to put your mind to other
reasons please do
um but body point two proposed five
dwellings uh not considered being
keeping with the local vernacular would
result in unsympathetic design well
i think if we're removing bullet point
three which talks about design clearly
we have no issue with design
um significant increase in traffic
five dwellings at best three cars to a
dwelling
let's say four that's 20 cars in a
category of three village that is
expected to accommodate a minimum of 450
homes
even at one car per those 450 i can't
really say that 20 cars is going to be
a significant increase i'm struggling
with that and an urbanization of the
site
i disagree as well i mean it's five
houses it was a real jam in there
then sure um but it's it's it's five
properties
um and naturally uh the organic growth
of local services villages local service
villages will naturally lead to a more
urbanized look um so i'm struggling to
agree with
that as a reason um to refuse and and
i've already spoken about
uh bullet point four as well the the
loss of um uh
rare garden land um i'm i'm not
comfortable with that leaves us really
with
uh cs16 the number of homes i've i've
talked about that before and i'm
uncomfortable with it
finally the traffic and highway issue um
short of there being real substantial
evidence presented to us which so far
hasn't been
um we have had comments from both our
ward member um
and indeed um i believe it was our
objector
rather than the parish council that's
right yeah dr khan um
we've heard from them to say that there
is an issue
but i don't have any traffic a traffic
planners rebuttal
to highways um saying that they're
comfortable
uh to say that they have no objection
because
of all that i don't believe that we are
in a position to be able to refuse this
and fight it robustly at an appeal
so with
some reluctance um i am going to put a
counter proposal in that we grant
in line with the officer's
recommendation
we do have a proposal to refuse and
counsel adam has given his reasons for
that
um i won't outline them again but we
know what they are
that was the first proposal i do need to
speak seek a secondary before i
uh seek a second for mine
councillor dixon i can see has seconded
councillor adam
council dixon do you want to speak to
that uh i basically my
my support is on the basis that it's a
refusal based on
uh bullet points one four and five
okay um i'm not gonna read them again
um we know what they are i've already
talked to them so you're happy to second
um i've made a proposal council proposal
as well
um while we're at this point i'm gonna
seek a seconder i can see councillor
kendall has indicated
is willingness to second do you want to
speak to that counselor kendall or are
you
happy for us to move on hello i'm happy
good man
okay so we must take the first proposal
first which is council adams that is to
refuse planning permission
uh on the basis that it breaches policy
cx
cs16 of our core strategy uh
the i.e the the numbers uh full detail
of wedding obviously we can put two
officers if
if this um is this this uh proposal is
successful um so cs16
uh highway safety
by virtue of the visibility display is
being achieved um
off mill lane when entering off the a3
400.
and i believe the cumulative effect of
the increase in traffic the urbanization
of the site
um and the loss of large open parcel
of land to the rear of the existing uh
creating an urbanization of the southern
fringe of newborns tower
that is the reasoning for it um i will
go first council richards against
thank you councillor fleming
dixon for councillor jennings
councillor jennings against yeah that's
three four and three against
oh joyous that leaves it to my uh i have
the um
uh casting vote don't i uh in which case
i will maintain my position
um and we uh that proposal has
failed therefore we will move to the
second proposal which was to grant in
line with us with officers
recommendation
council richards four
fleming flaring against
kendall that's the kendall four
councillor adam adam again
councillor dixon against
and councillor jennings councillor
jennings
regrettably four chair that's three four
and three against
well what a big shock it's my casting
votes again and i will continue to
maintain the position i have set out
which is to grant
so committee therefore resolves to grant
application twenty zero
two six six one ful that's green acres
mill lane in newbold on
star there being no urgent business
uh it uh it leaves me to say thank you
very much
to all of our speakers this evening for
their contributions
and their patience with our technical
glitches thank you to all our members
and in particular thank you to all of
our officers for their time and effort
this evening
thank you very much everyone and good
night good night